Hey everybody. So we have an awesome episode here. I remember the kind of first time I saw GraphQL. And I remember it's just kind of a magical thing. We're going to dive into it. I'm not going to kind of spoil it or anything. But it is something that kind of really spoke to me. I think in general, when you look at the way that you can sort of design sending information over the web, I think GraphQL allows you
大家好。我们这里有一期非常棒的节目。我记得我第一次接触到 GraphQL 的时候。我记得那真是一种神奇的东西。我们要深入探讨它。我不会剧透或者什么的。但它确实是那种真正触动我的东西。我觉得总的来说，当你看到可以通过某种方式设计在网络上传输信息时，我认为 GraphQL 允许你
to do a lot with very little. It's a really powerful tool and I'm really excited to talk about it. A lot of people don't know about it. And so a lot of folks out there listening, this might be the first time you're hearing GraphQL. You might be thinking, oh, is this a new sequel or something? No, it's very different. We're going to cover it from top to bottom. And to do that, we have Tanmay Gopal,
用非常少的工作量做很多事情。这是一个非常强大的工具，我很高兴能谈论它。很多人并不知道它。所以对于许多在听节目的朋友来说，这可能是你第一次听说 GraphQL。你可能会想，哦，这是一个新的 SQL 还是别的什么？不，它非常不同。我们将从头到尾全面介绍它。为了做到这一点，我们请到了
who's CEO of Pesura, to cover it. So thanks so much for coming on the show, Tanmay. Thanks for having me. Great to be here. Great. Yes. So, you know, before we get into GraphQL, we always love to hear about our guests, like where they, you know, kind of came from in their careers. You know, what did you study?
Hasura 的首席执行官 Tanmay Gopal 来为我们讲解。非常感谢你能来参加节目，Tanmay。谢谢邀请我。很高兴来到这里。太好了。是的。那么，你知道，在我们深入探讨 GraphQL 之前，我们总是很喜欢了解我们的嘉宾，比如他们的职业背景是怎样的。你知道，你学的是什么？
Were you coding on Atari at four years old? Or did you start getting into coding at 34 years old? You know, what's the journey like? And what's the path that took you to Asura? So I'd love to hear more. I started programming fairly late in my life in university. And I think until I was in university, I wanted to kind of do kind of more pure science-y kind of stuff,
你四岁时就在 Atari 上写代码了吗？还是你在 34 岁时才开始接触编程？你知道，这段经历是怎样的？是什么路径让你创办了 Hasura？所以我很想听听更多。我开始编程的时间在生命中相对较晚，是在上大学的时候。我想直到上大学前，我都想从事更偏向纯科学性质的工作，
which appealed to me more. And then during kind of like my pre-university years the idea that we've kind of been able to create a world that is entirely on our own terms that is to a large degree disassociated from the natural law right like you don't have to worry about physics like you're building a bridge you need to care about like the wind and the earth right but when you're doing something on a machine and care about like the wind and the earth right but when you're doing something on a machine and we've kind of built this world of software and the internet it's kind of insane how that happened and so and how that happened and and and how we did that was
这对我更有吸引力。然后在我大学预科的那几年里，那种我们能够创造一个完全按照我们自己的条件构建的世界的想法，它在很大程度上脱离了自然规律，对吧——比如你不需要担心物理学，如果你在建一座桥，你需要关心风和地球，对吧？但当你在机器上做某事时，你可以不用关心风和地球，对吧？但当你在机器上做某事时，我们已经构建了这个由软件和互联网组成的世界，发生这种事简直太疯狂了。所以，这是如何发生的，我们又是如何做到这一点的，
was just like an idea that was stuck in my head and i really wanted to find out how this was built and that's the reason I wanted to then kind of study computer science. And so that's what I started in university. I did my bachelor's and my master's. For my master's, I then specialized in... I covered a lot of breadth while I was in university on different kinds of computer science topics. And for my master's work,
这个想法一直盘旋在我的脑海里，我真的很想弄清楚这是怎么构建的，这就是我想去学习计算机科学的原因。所以我大学开始学这个。我读完了本科和硕士。在读硕士期间，我在大学里涉猎了各种不同计算机科学主题的广泛知识。在我的硕士研究工作中，
I specialized in machine learning and computer vision. I did some research work that I sold off to the Defense Org in India. Wait, so let's dive into that a little bit. So I think if, and tell me if I'm not paraphrasing this correctly. So when you're doing your undergrad, it was in more of the hard sciences. And then for your master's, you switched to computer science, right? Pre-undergrad, I thought I wanted to do more pure sciences stuff. But then when I had to choose kind of a work stream for my undergrad, I decided to do computer science.
我专注于机器学习和计算机视觉。我做了一些研究工作，并将其卖给了印度的国防机构。等等，让我们深入探讨一下。我想如果——如果我没有准确转述的话请纠正我——你读本科时，学的是更偏向硬科学的专业。然后到了读硕士时，你转到了计算机科学，对吧？在本科之前，我以为我想从事更偏向纯科学的工作。但后来当我要为本科选择一个方向时，我决定学计算机科学。
Okay, got it. So what was that like? So, you know, I think I had a somewhat similar thing where I was pretty sure I was going to be in math, like a math major. And then I got to college and I went with computer science. And so, you know, in your case, you know, what was that like? Like, where did the mindset change? And how did that evolve? I think it was like this, just in terms of the amount of things that we are able to do as humans, it felt like we could just do so much more because we created kind of this this world in our own terms right this abstraction on hardware that was software right that it's video games or
好的，明白了。那段经历是怎样的？你知道，我想我有过类似经历，我当时很确定自己会学数学，比如主修数学。然后我上了大学，却选择了计算机科学。所以，对你来说，那段经历是怎样的？心态是如何转变的，又是如何演变的？我觉得就像是，仅就人类能够做的事情的数量而言，感觉我们能做的事情要多得多，因为我们以自己的方式创造了这个世界，这个建立在硬件之上的抽象层就是软件，无论是电子游戏还是
or code or the internet or whatever right so i felt like that's all i understood about computers i didn't even i didn't understand anything else i you know i'd used computers before of course and and i played around with programming in school i think once or twice and it was very interesting but then kind of that thing got stuck in my head because most of your school years right you're kind of studying you're doing like basic physics and chemistry and biology and stuff like that right and um and that was very interesting but i felt like from what i had studied to where the world was, there was a bit of a gap. And I wanted to kind of unpack what that gap was, right? It's like, sure, like we understand these electrons and things,
代码、互联网还是其他什么，对吧？所以我感觉这就是我对计算机的全部理解，我甚至对其他一无所知。你知道，我以前当然用过计算机，而且我在学校里也玩过一两次编程，这非常有趣。但后来那种想法就卡在我脑海里了，因为在学校的大部分时间里，你都在学习、做一些基础的物理、化学和生物之类的东西，对吧？而且这非常有趣，但我感觉从我所学的知识到现实世界之间，存在着一点差距。我想弄清楚那个差距是什么，对吧？就像，当然，我们了解电子这些东西，
and we understand like, like we understand electricity, we're kind of, we had semiconductors, and we kind of get in there, like you're kind of feeling that the building blocks are coming together, but there's still a little bit of a leap before that just transitions into this virtual world or into this thing, right? And so I really wanted to unpack that. How did that happen? That's the only thing I knew. That was the only agenda I had to kind of figure out how that happened. And that's kind of what pulled me towards studying computer science. Does that make sense? Yeah, totally. Yeah. I mean, I have kind of a similar experience where I think
我们了解，就像我们了解电一样，我们有了半导体，然后我们深入其中，就像你能感觉到这些基础模块组合在了一起，但在它转化为虚拟世界或变成那个东西之前，仍然有一个小的跨越，对吧？所以我真的很想弄清楚这一点。这是怎么发生的？这是我唯一的想法。我唯一的目的就是弄清楚这是怎么发生的。这就是吸引我去学习计算机科学的原因。这说得通吗？是的，完全说得通。是的，我的经历其实也有点相似，我觉得
if you look at math and economics, you know, you build these models with a ton of assumptions and they're relatively simple models. And then you can, you know, like I'm thinking about differential equations here. There's probably a ton of others. But then, you know, you look at the computer world. And I mean, when I was in high school, Half-Life came out, the original Half-Life game. And I remember seeing there was this demo where there were barrels. They basically made Plinko. You know, Plinko from, it's this game where you drop a disc and you have a bunch of pegs on a board, and the disc kind of bounces among the pegs and then falls in one of the buckets.
如果你看看数学和经济学，你知道，你用大量的假设建立这些模型，它们是相对简单的模型。然后你可以，你知道——我这里想到的是微分方程。可能还有很多其他的。但然后，你知道，你看看计算机世界。我的意思是，当我上高中时，《半条命》（Half-Life）发售了，那是最初的《半条命》游戏。我记得看到过一个演示，里面有木桶。他们基本上用它做了个弹珠台游戏（Plinko）。你知道 Plinko 吗，就是那种你丢下一个圆盘，板上有一堆钉子，圆盘在钉子间弹跳，然后落入其中一个桶里的游戏。
And you assign points to different buckets. It's a lot of fun. So the Half-Life, when they were showing off the game, the developers basically built Plinko in the Half-Life engine, and they dropped one of these explosive barrels, and it just bounced on these pegs and went into the hole. I got really enamored by that. It's like, wow, what a complex system that these handful of folks
然后你给不同的桶分配分数。这非常有趣。所以《半条命》在展示游戏时，开发人员基本上在《半条命》引擎里做了个 Plinko 游戏，他们扔下其中一个爆炸桶，它就在这些钉子上弹跳并掉进了洞里。我真的被迷住了。这就像，哇，这帮家伙竟然凭空创造出了如此复杂的系统。
just created out of thin air. It's just something really powerful there exactly right and i kind of wanted to really unpack that and then that's kind of what the undergrad was like oh very cool so you went to grad school then you did a small company that was doing some work with the military and then then, yeah, what happened after that? After studying, when I wanted to kind of figure out what to do in the real world, right? I think during those kind of last few years in my undergrad and then while doing my master's, I thought,
这里面确实有一种非常强大的力量，完全正确。我当时就想真正弄清楚这一点，这就是我本科经历的写照。哦，非常酷！所以你后来上了研究生，做了一家为军方做点事情的小公司，然后呢，之后发生了什么？学习结束后，当我想弄清楚在现实世界中要做什么时，对吧？我想在我本科的最后几年和读硕士期间，
maybe I want to do research. But then when I did some research and I was like, nah, this is still too slow. I want like a shorter feedback loop i want to be able to do something and then have impact and so then what i did was i just kind of went into industry and started doing my own like freelance consulting initially in the space that i was in and then kind of gradually just trying to understand take stock of what is happening with companies across the world and what are kind of the key challenges they're
我想，也许我想做研究。但当我做了一些研究后，我觉得：不，这还是太慢了。我想要一个更短的反馈循环，我想要能够做成某事并产生影响。所以后来我做的事是，我直接进入了工业界，开始在我原先的领域进行我自己的自由职业咨询。然后逐渐地，我试图了解并评估世界各地公司正在发生的事情，以及他们在拓展构建产品的能力、构建数字产品以及将产品推向市场等方面正在挣扎的关键挑战是什么。所以在接下来的几年里，我创办了一家咨询公司，我把一群来自大学的朋友等人聚在一起，建立了一家小型咨询公司。
struggling with in terms of kind of scaling their ability to build products and build digital products and take things to market and stuff like that and so for the next few years I started a consulting firm and I got together a bunch of folks from you know from university and friends and stuff like that and built out a small consulting firm. And what we did was we worked with companies of all shapes and sizes with, like, global, like, banks to tiny startups to, you know, brick-and-mortar companies building their first digital product and stuff like that.
我们做的事情是，我们与各种规模的公司合作，从全球性银行到初创小公司，再到建立他们第一个数字产品的传统实体公司等等。
And during that time, what we kind of did was we built products for them. And internally, a few of us have kind of like a platform team and what we were trying to figure out was what needs to be done to make this whole process of building things faster and and the reason why we set up that platform team was because me and my co-founder today at Hasura in in our previous company we wanted to build out a small application it was like a food e-commerce type thing just just for kicks and i thought it'd be really easy to build and and as i went through that process of developing the application i got so angry
在这期间，我们为他们构建产品。在公司内部，我们中的几个人组成了平台团队，我们试图弄清楚需要做什么才能使构建东西的整个过程更快。我们建立那个平台团队的原因是因为我和我现在的 Hasura 联合创始人在我们之前的公司里想构建一个小型应用程序，它类似于食品电商类的东西，纯粹是为了好玩，我以为这会非常容易构建。但在开发这个应用程序的过程中，我变得非常生气。
i got really really angry i was like this is not okay like this is just way too much work yeah this is like we're doing too much work for doing. This is like, this was the time when we had like things like Ionic and Ionic was just coming out. There's a thing called jQuery mobile. I don't know if you remember.
我变得非常非常生气，我觉得：这太不正常了，这简直是太多的工作了。是的，这就好比我们在做过多的工作。这就像——这是我们有像 Ionic 这样的技术的时期，Ionic 刚刚问世。当时有个东西叫 jQuery Mobile。我不知道你是否还记得。
Oh man, I remember that. It was, it looked so janky, right? Web components and polymer, like polymer web components
天哪，我记得那个。它看起来太山寨了，对吧？网页组件（web components）和 Polymer，比如 Polymer 网页组件
or something Google is just starting to come out, right? Twitter had a flimical flight. Oh, that's right. Yeah. So these kinds of little things were just starting to come out, right? Twitter had a flimical flight. Oh, that's right. Yeah. So these kind of little things were just happening.
或者谷歌刚刚开始推出的东西，对吧？Twitter 当时有 Flight。哦，对的。是的。所以这些小东西当时才刚开始出现，对吧？Twitter 当时有 Flight。哦，对的。是的。所以这些小东西当时才刚发生。
But regardless, it was a time of tremendous amount of frustration, both on the front end side and the API side. It was like, we are just doing too much work. We don't need to specify so many things. I mean, computer science has moved on. Yeah. I feel like in many ways, mobile is still frustrating. I think on the web, for example, if you want to plot a time series on the web, you would just go to GitHub, you'd find
但无论如何，那是一个充满巨大挫折感的时代，无论是在前端还是在 API 方面。当时的感觉就是：我们只是在做太多的工作。我们不需要指定这么多的东西。我的意思是，计算机科学已经前进了。是的。我觉得在很多方面，移动端仍然令人沮丧。我认为在网页端，例如，如果你想在网页端绘制时间序列图，你只需去 GitHub，找到
a time series library, you would add it to your package.json file, and you're good to go. There's solid documentation. With React, you have pretty good isolation among the different components. You don't have to worry about that. On mobile, it's still a mess. If you want to plot a time series on mobile, you go on GitHub, you find some graph package that probably has like 13 GitHub stars. You plug it in. Oh, it's in Java and all your stuff's in Kotlin.
一个时间序列库，把它加到你的 package.json 文件里，然后就大功告成了。有坚实的文档。使用 React，你在不同的组件之间有相当好的隔离。你不用担心这个。在移动端，这仍然是一团糟。如果你想在移动端绘制时间序列图，你去 GitHub，找到某个大概只有 13 个 GitHub Star 的图表包。你把它插进去。哦，它是用 Java 写的，而你的所有东西都是用 Kotlin 写的。
And now you have to deal with interop and everything. And it's like, oh, I can't render on the main thread. It causes an exception. It's just like, it's just the experience is very painful. And so, you know, that's the thing that when these things started coming out, like Cordera, I think was one, Ionic, these things where you could take your website and put it on the phone, that was so appealing but then as you said they were also super janky you're in this kind of uncanny valley where it worked enough
现在你必须处理互操作性（interop）和所有这些问题。感觉就是，哦，我不能在主线程上渲染。这会导致异常。这就像，这种体验非常痛苦。所以，你知道，当这些东西开始出现时，比如 Cordera（译者注：应为 Cordova），我想是一个，还有 Ionic，你可以把你的网站放到手机上，这太有吸引力了。但正如你所说，它们也非常山寨，你处于这种恐怖谷中，它足够好用，
that people knew it wasn't a native app and they didn't like it and it's just it was it was totally frustrating yeah exactly right and and so we i was like we have to fix this we're going to do something so that so that we improve this and the number of developers in the world ought to be like hundreds of millions, right? It's still just tens of millions, barely. And so it needs to be hundreds of millions for the amount of impact that this has.
以至于人们知道它不是原生应用，而且他们不喜欢它，这简直太令人沮丧了。是的，完全正确。所以我们当时就想：我们必须修复这个。我们要采取行动来改善这一点。世界上开发人员的数量本该有数亿，对吧？但实际上仍然只有数千万，勉勉强强。为了达到它应有的影响力，它必须达到数亿的规模。
And the world is going there, right? We are on that trajectory. It's not like it's not going to happen. It is going to happen. How do we help accelerate that? What are the pieces of the problem that need to be solved to kind of make that unlock
世界正在朝那个方向发展，对吧？我们正沿着这条轨迹前进。并不是说它不会发生。它一定会发生。我们如何帮助加速这一进程？需要解决哪些问题才能让这种解锁过程
as systematic as possible, right? As like as systemic and systematic as possible. And the technologies that really appeal to me and that appeal to us in the founding team were things like, you know,
尽可能系统化，对吧？尽可能具有系统性和体系化。真正吸引我和我们创始团队的技术是，你知道，
databases really appeal to us and programming languages and compilers really appeal to us because it's such a nice way of translating like a higher level way of thinking into a lower level abstraction that something like a machine can understand, right? And databases are such a brilliant example of doing that, right?
数据库对我们非常有吸引力，编程语言和编译器也对我们非常有吸引力，因为这是一种将高级思维方式转化为底层抽象的绝妙方式，可以让机器之类的东西理解，对吧？数据库就是一个这样做的绝佳例子，对吧？
Because if you don't have databases, like you'll be reading and writing to files every time you wanted to build something instead of kind of capturing domain models and saying, oh, I have a time series model and so chuck it into a time series database, right? Or have an unstructured data model, chuck it into a JSON database. I have a structured table with relationships and that's my domain.
因为如果你没有数据库，每当你想要构建什么东西时，你都得对文件进行读写，而不是去捕获领域模型并说：“哦，我有一个时间序列模型，所以把它扔进时间序列数据库里，对吧？”或者“有一个非结构化数据模型，把它扔进 JSON 数据库里。我有一个带有关联关系的结构化表格，这就是我的领域。”
And so you chuck that into a Postgres or whatever, right? So those things were really appealing to us. And we were like, what needs to be, something needs to be there to make this process easier. And so with kind of a phase of like a lot of experimentation, a lot of learning what companies and what the industry is doing we were super early in kind of the cloud native ecosystem we played around with docker and kubernetes both when they were pre 1.0 we built the world's first kubernetes operator so that did did like a tremendous number of uh super early in
所以你把它扔进 Postgres 或其他什么数据库里，对吧？所以这些东西对我们真的很有吸引力。我们当时就在想，一定得有什么东西来让这个过程变得更简单。因此，经过大量的实验和对公司及行业发展方向的学习，我们在云原生生态系统中起步非常早。我们在 Docker 和 Kubernetes 处于 1.0 版本之前就玩过它们了。我们构建了世界上第一个 Kubernetes 运营商（operator），所以做了大量的……在
the githubs movement as well i had one of the the first Git push to set up and deploy Kubernetes-based applications. I remember speaking at one of the first KubeCons. So we did kind of a bunch of things to understand kind of where the industry is going, what kind of things are happening, what kinds of interventions are required. One of the other things that we also did during this time was also like understand what the gaps in learning are.
GitHub 兴起运动中也极其超前。我有过最早的用于设置和部署基于 Kubernetes 的应用程序的 Git push 提交之一。我记得我在最早的 KubeCon 大会上演讲过。所以我们做了一堆事情来了解行业的发展方向、正在发生的事情以及需要进行什么样的干预。在这个过程中，我们做的另一件事也是了解学习上的差距。
And we ran this course on introduction to modern application development, which we kind of just said, all you need is a browser and you're going to learn how just web application development works. Wait, let's double click into that. So how did you get to running that course?
我们开设了一门名为“现代应用开发导论”的课程，我们当时只是说，你只需要一个浏览器，你就能了解网络应用开发是如何工作的。等等，让我们深入探讨一下。你是怎么开始开办这门课程的？
Like, did someone approach you? Did you go to Coursera and say, I love your platform or like whoever and say, I love your platform. Let me put a course. How did that happen? I went to a professor that I knew in university who I quite liked. And I went to him and I said, hey, we should just do this course because like, university doesn't teach it. The university that I come from in India is a fairly famous university and they do these. It's a part of a network of universities that do a lot of online courses
是有谁来找你吗？你去找 Coursera 并说：我喜欢你们的平台，或者不管是谁，说：我喜欢你们的平台。让我开一门课。这事是怎么发生的？我去找了一位我在大学里认识且很喜欢的教授。我去找他并说：嘿，我们应该开这门课，因为大学里不教这个。我来自印度的大学是一所相当著名的大学，他们做这些。它是印度一所提供大量在线课程的大学网络的一部分。
is this iit i've heard the word iit before okay yeah yeah yeah this is one it's an it's an idea and so they run these online courses that like everybody like a lot of people in india kind of use which is usually more advanced engineering courses right and so what i said was hey let's do this course where we kind of introduce like modern application development right because nobody really like it's not covered in the university syllabus and people don't people really want to understand it right it's like i'm using this google.com thing for search how what what happens right like how is this thing working like what's the what are the layers here uh what are the concepts here that come together
这是 IIT 吗？我以前听过 IIT 这个词。哦，对，对，对，这是一所 IIT。所以他们开设了这些在线课程，印度很多人都会用，通常是更高级的工程课程，对吧？所以我当时说的是：嘿，我们来开这门课吧，我们在其中介绍现代应用开发，因为大学教学大纲里真的没有涵盖这一点，人们真的很想了解它，对吧？就像我在用这个 Google.com 进行搜索一样，到底发生了什么？这东西是怎么运作的？这里的层级是什么？有哪些概念组合在一起
to make this thing work, right? And then obviously give people a feel for like writing a little bit of a hello world and then seeing that work inside of a browser. And so we put this course together. We built like a browser sandbox environment where you can write code and you can see a website go live.
让这个东西工作，对吧？然后显然要让人们感受一下编写一点“Hello World”并在浏览器中看到它运行。所以我们把这门课程拼凑了起来。我们构建了一个浏览器沙盒环境，你可以在其中编写代码，并看到一个网站上线。
I think it became one of the largest Kubernetes clusters at the time. I think it had like a 700 node cluster to power this because we had like 250,000 students in a year that went through the program. And that was fascinating as well to kind of take a look at and see this is how much people really want to learn. This is how much people really want to do and have agency and understand how these things work and then use it to build something. Yeah, I feel like, you know, just
我想它成了当时最大的 Kubernetes 集群之一。我想它拥有一个大约 700 个节点的集群来支持这个运行，因为我们一年有 25 万名学生参加了这个项目。这也是一件令人着迷的事情，去观察并发现人们是多么渴望学习。人们是多么渴望去做这件事，拥有自主权并了解这些东西是如何运作的，然后用它来构建一些东西。是的，我觉得，你知道，只需
double click on that. I feel like, you know, I'm a big fan of university. I mean, I got a PhD. I really enjoyed my time there. But, you know, one of the things that it did not prepare me for is writing modern software at all. The code behind my PhD dissertation, say the PhD project or something, it was all just XML files. I was like by hand editing XML files to configure everything. And even when I was writing all the statistics out, I was writing those in JSON and XML files and then trying to by hand look at it. And I remember at one point writing a Python program to like read in an XML
深入探讨一下。我觉得，我是大学的超级粉丝。我的意思是，我拿到了博士学位。我非常享受在那里的时光。但是，你知道，它没有为我做好的准备之一就是编写现代软件。我的博士论文背后的代码，比如博士项目之类的，全都是 XML 文件。我当时是在手动编辑 XML 文件来配置所有东西。甚至当我写出所有的统计数据时，我也是把它们写进 JSON 和 XML 文件中，然后试图手动去查看它们。我记得有一次写了一个 Python 程序来读取 XML
file and compute the average of all the entries in the file. And basically, like I could have probably graduated half a year earlier if I had just someone had just told me what SQLite was, you know, or MySQL or whatever. Like, yeah, I had no background in databases. I had no background in networking. And I was completely ill prepared to build anything significant. And so, yeah, what you're what you're touching on is extremely, extremely powerful. And so no matter how, like, theoretical you are, just take the time to learn how to build a modern you know website or a modern app it's so important yep yep and and and for everybody across the country right i
文件并计算文件中所有条目的平均值。基本上，如果当时有人告诉我什么是 SQLite，或者 MySQL 之类的，我可能可以提前半年毕业。是的，我没有数据库背景。我没有网络背景。我完全没有准备好构建任何重要的东西。所以，是的，你所触及的东西是非常非常强大的。因此，无论你的理论有多深厚，都要花时间学习如何构建一个现代网站或现代应用程序，这太重要了。是的，是的，而且为了全国的每个人，我
remember we had like some of the students who joined that course for people who were like professionals you know who'd worked for a decade two decades in a completely different industry not even like technical or sciencey and or just're just like, I want to build a thing. And, you know, I want to see what it feels like. And it's fascinating, right? Because like you can actually do it. Like you can convert an idea into a thing. It's possible today.
记得我们有一些参加这门课程的学生是专业人士，他们在一个完全不同的行业工作了十年、二十年，甚至都不是技术或科学背景，他们只是觉得：“我想构建一个东西。”而且，“我想看看那是什么感觉。”这太迷人了，对吧？因为你真的可以做到。你可以把一个想法变成一个实体。这在今天是可能的。
So we did a whole set of things basically is what I'm trying to say. And of all of these things that we did, the piece that stood out to us the most was this idea that when we kind of take a step back, this is around 2018, 2019, when we kind of take a step back and we look at where the industry is going, our hypothesis was that the data experience is going to keep improving. We were in a world in the 80s and 90s when the databases first came along,
所以我想表达的是，我们做了一整套事情。在我们所做的一切事情中，最吸引我们的部分是这样一种想法：当我们退后一步来看，这是在大约 2018 年、2019 年左右，当我们退后一步观察行业发展方向时，我们的假设是数据体验将不断改善。我们在 80 年代和 90 年代数据库刚出现的时候经历过一个世界，
which became the perfect place to model your domain and then interact with your domain, right? That's what the database became. It said, instead of you trying to screw around with files, why don't you chuck stuff into a table and then you have this amazing language like SQL to be able to query that database and interact with it. Right?
数据库成了对你的领域进行建模并与之交互的完美场所，对吧？数据库就是这样诞生的。它说，与其让你去跟文件死磕，为什么不把东西扔进表格里，然后你就有像 SQL 这样神奇的语言来查询数据库并与之交互呢？对吧？
And that was amazing. And then we kind of went through this thing where the database companies became a little too greedy. Everybody wanted to buy an island or two. And they kind of really penalized, right? They really penalized people in the industry to start actually working and having business logic in the database and doing things like that. And so people wanted to start taking that outside of the database.
这太棒了。然后我们经历了一个阶段，数据库公司变得有点太贪婪了。每个人都想买一个或两个小岛。他们确实惩罚了，对吧？他们确实惩罚了行业中那些开始真正在数据库中编写业务逻辑并做诸如此类事情的人。所以人们希望开始把这些逻辑移出数据库。
And so they started building applications that would let them interact with the database, right? And so you build applications. These applications that the internet came along became application servers and HTML, which became like the front end, right? So it kind of like went from one place where things would happen into two, into three, right? When suddenly you had the web as well. And then 2010 onwards, that like the third end of it, the web experience, the mobile experience became very rich
于是他们开始构建能够让与数据库交互的应用程序，对吧？然后你构建应用程序。随着互联网的兴起，这些应用程序成了应用服务器和 HTML（它成了前端），对吧？所以它从事情发生的一个地方变成两个地方，再变成三个地方，对吧？当网络也突然出现时。然后从 2010 年开始，网络的第三端——网络体验、移动体验变得非常丰富，
because of the mobile kind of improvement that happened. And with iPhones, smartphones, whatever. And that's kind of where products were getting built, and then we had these apis in the middle and then you had data stores and those data stores were scaling for a long time right like 2005 onwards everybody was very frustrated like my databases are not scaling but then again around 2015 2016 we again reached kind of that point where databases figured out how they're going to kind of become more scalable. And we started seeing the first distributed relational databases, we started seeing the NoSQL databases also adding more database features, becoming closer to relational databases, but also kind of providing that kind of read-write performance at scale.
这是因为移动端的发展发生了，伴随着 iPhone、智能手机等。这就是产品的构建方式，我们在中间有了这些 API，然后你有了数据存储，这些数据存储很长一段时间都在扩展，对吧？比如从 2005 年开始，每个人都非常沮丧：“我的数据库无法扩展。”但随后，在大约 2015 年、2016 年，我们再次达到了这样一个点：数据库找到了如何变得更具可扩展性的方法。我们开始看到第一批分布式关系型数据库，我们开始看到 NoSQL 数据库也增加了更多数据库功能，变得更接近关系型数据库，同时也提供这种规模化的读写性能。
Yeah, that's an interesting story, right? Like, you know, MySQL, Postgres were the biggest thing. And then there was a period where it was all HBase, Cassandra, and all of these type of efforts. But then it seems like we've almost gone back. I think what it is, is MySQL and Postgres are so much easier to shard now, that people have kind of gone back to that and hbase is probably you know just a less than one percent yeah yeah it is it is still too low level right because you can get because what is amazing about postgres and mysql is how rich they are and their capability and what you can do with them they just want scaling and then people figured out how to make them scale and now so we're back to kind of being able to use things like postgres and mysql right so when we kind of like looked at the data industry right we were like we looked at the database industry we were like the database industry is going to keep figuring it out they were in a place where you can now have a managed database and if you choose your workload
是的，这是一个有趣的故事，对吧？就像，MySQL、Postgres 是最大的东西。然后有一个时期，到处都是 HBase、Cassandra 和所有这些努力。但随后，我们似乎几乎又回去了。我想原因在于，MySQL 和 Postgres 现在分片（shard）要容易得多，所以人们基本上又回去了，Hbase 可能只占不到百分之一吧。是的，是的，它确实仍然太底层了，因为你能得到的——Postgres 和 MySQL 的神奇之处在于它们有多么丰富、功能有多么强大以及你能用它们做什么。它们只是需要扩展，然后人们找到了让它们扩展的方法，现在我们又回到了可以使用 Postgres 和 MySQL 这样的技术的时候。所以当我们审视数据行业时，我们觉得——我们审视了数据库行业，我们觉得数据库行业会不断摸索出方法，他们已经到了这样一个阶段：你现在可以拥有一个托管数据库，如果你选择你的工作负载，
and you map your workload and a part of your domain right whatever your domain is you map part of your domain and you choose the right kind of database for it. You'll get like really, really good scalability, right? It'll keep working for you for a really long time. Like you can, you'll have to start kind of touching like Facebook, Google scale for you to start stressing out about your database. But short of that, you're probably not going to have to stress about your database at all.
并映射你的工作负载以及你领域的一部分——无论你的领域是什么，你映射一部分领域并为其选择正确类型的数据库。你会得到非常非常好的可扩展性，对吧？它会为你工作很长一段时间。你需要达到 Facebook、Google 的规模，才会开始为你的数据库感到焦虑。但在那之前，你可能根本不需要为你的数据库感到焦虑。
It will just be a managed service that runs. You know, you can say that it's a very heavily transactional or it's super relational or it's time-saving or whatever it is, right? Well, now there's even the serverless, like there's Aurora from AWS, where it's a completely serverless MySQL. And I don't even know honestly how that works because they have to reverse engineer your intent. You know, it that works, because they don't, they have to reverse engineer your intent. You know, it's like, you don't really, I don't think you even have that many knobs to tune. But just as your demand scales up, it sort of figures out how to distribute that load. It's remarkable.
它将只是一项运行中的托管服务。你知道，你可以说它是重度事务型的，或者是超级关系型的，或者是时间序列的，或者其他什么，对吧？现在甚至还有无服务器（serverless）的，比如 AWS 的 Aurora，它是一个完全无服务器的 MySQL。老实说，我甚至不知道它是如何工作的，因为它们必须逆向工程你的意图。你知道，它就是能工作，因为它们不需要——它们必须逆向工程你的意图。你知道，就像，你真的——我认为你甚至不需要调整那么多的参数。但随着你的需求规模扩大，它会自行弄清楚如何分发负载。这太了不起了。
Yep, yep, yep. And like they separated, people started learning this idea of like separating compute from storage, right? And then really exploiting cloud. And that's how they managed to do this, right? And the OLAP ecosystem is improving. The time series databases and real-time analytics databases
是的，是的，是的。而且它们分离了——人们开始学习这种将计算与存储分离的思想，对吧？然后真正利用云。这就是它们成功做到这一点的方式，对吧？OLAP 生态系统正在改善。时间序列数据库和实时分析数据库
have gotten really good, right? Whether it's like you look at the generation of like OLAP and data warehouses that really took off on the cloud, whether it's like Snowflake, BigQuery, Databricks type systems, and then you have like the real-time analytics versions of it, like whether you click house and do it in Ign real-time analytics versions of it, like Clickhouse
已经变得非常出色了，无论你看的是在云端腾飞的 OLAP 和数据仓库这一代技术，无论是 Snowflake、BigQuery、Databricks 这样的系统，然后你还有其实时分析版本，比如 ClickHouse 和 Druid、Ignite 以及 SimpleStore。
and Druid and Ignite and SimpleStore. It's amazing, right? There's no one database that's going to do everything, but you can take bits of your domain and chuck it onto the right data stores, and it's great. It's just phenomenal. It works. Yeah, and Clickhouse is completely open open source so it really kind of took the bigquery snowflake ecosystem and and now it's like almost becoming a commodity as soon as
这太棒了，对吧？没有哪个单一的数据库能包办一切，但你可以截取你的领域的一部分，把它扔到正确的数据库里，这就很棒了。这简直是个奇迹。它行之有效。是的，而且 ClickHouse 是完全开源的，所以它真的接管了 BigQuery 和 Snowflake 生态系统，现在它几乎正在成为一种商品。一旦
someone open source comes on the market it completely disrupts everything yep exactly right and so so we kind of were getting the sense that this is going to happen so this experience is going to be amazing so kind of when you're thinking about building a product, you're like, okay, so the data stack is going to work. That's great. And it's going to keep improving. It's going to keep fragmenting. It's going to keep improving. But that's great, too. We look at the product building side of things, right? When you're looking
某个开源产品进入市场，它就会彻底颠覆一切。是的，完全正确。所以我们当时有一种感觉，这将会发生，所以这种体验将会非常棒。因此，当你考虑构建产品时，你会想，好吧，数据栈将会发挥作用。这很棒。它会不断改进。它会不断碎片化。它会不断改进。但这也是好事。我们看看产品构建这一端，对吧？当你观察
at your JavaScript frameworks and whatnot, we started seeing early signs of React becoming very popular. The meta frameworks in React were just starting. And it looked like that experience was also on its way to becoming... There was this continuous increase in complexity, as always, and fragmentation.
你的 JavaScript 框架及其他东西时，我们开始看到 React 变得非常流行的早期迹象。React 中的元框架（meta-frameworks）刚刚起步。看起来这种体验也正在走向……复杂度一直在持续增加，一如既往，而且伴随着碎片化。
But that experience was getting better. And at least if not... All of us in web development think that we're still doing a little too much work on that side of like building the product and like trying to wrangle like 10 javascript libraries to doing something and whatever but it is continuously becoming better and and at least what you have there is what is happening is the agency is really high meaning that you're kind of able to go build a thing and then you're able to refactor that and change that and do something
但这种体验正在变好。而且即使不是……我们所有从事网页开发的人都认为，我们在产品构建这一端（比如试图拼凑 10 个 JavaScript 库来做某事等等）仍然做了太多工作，但它一直在持续变好，并且至少你在那里拥有的是，主动性非常高，这意味着你能够去构建一个东西，然后你能够重构它、改变它并做其他事情，
else and like keep evolving very quickly right like your best practices evolve quickly but then you can start using them in production also pretty easily which is great because if that's happening that means you can keep evolving right and so you don't need to do one um and so the product building experience was getting great right the part that sucked from our point of view was the piece in the middle, which is this piece of API development, right? Because we're like, this API development piece, our gut sense was that we aren't adding too much value here, right?
并且能够非常快地不断演进，对吧？就像你的最佳实践演变得很快，然后你也可以相当轻松地将它们投入生产，这太棒了，因为如果发生了这种情况，这就意味着你可以不断演进，所以你不需要做一……因此，产品构建体验变得非常棒，对吧？从我们的角度来看，糟糕的部分是中间的那一块，也就是 API 开发这块，对吧？因为我们觉得，这个 API 开发部分，我们的直觉是我们在这里并没有增加太多价值，对吧？
There is something that needs to be done, right? But why is it not product and data? Why is there this middle layer of the API, right? And so we kind of took a step back and said, what if, what if products that are end user facing, right?
一定有什么事情需要做，对吧？但为什么不是产品和数据？为什么中间会有这个 API 层，对吧？所以我们退后一步说：如果——如果面向最终用户的产品，对吧？
And that might be running on your device or your browser or being run in a different organization or different team in my company is running this product. Why can't that product speak to my domain data directly? Why? What's this thing in the middle? Yeah, the thing that has been there for a while, and I'd love you to burn this straw man down, would be ORMs. I think the superficial answer is, oh, we've had ORMs forever. Correct, correct, right? We've had ORMs forever.
这些产品可能在你的设备、浏览器上运行，或者在我公司的不同组织或不同团队中运行。为什么这个产品不能直接与我的领域数据对话？为什么？中间这个东西是什么？是的，那个存在了一段时间、我很希望你把这个稻草人烧掉的东西，就是 ORM（对象关系映射）。我认为表面上的回答是，哦，我们永远都有 ORM。没错，没错，对吧？我们永远都有 ORM。
And I think even with ORMs, right, when you think about it, the question really is, so you have a front-end application, right? You have a bank, like an application, like a bank app, right? And your bank app needs to do a transaction or whatever, right? Why can't the bank app talk to the bank's database directly? Why can't it just speak in SQL? That's what we used to do. That's what all developers know, right?
我想即使有了 ORM，对吧，当你仔细想想，真正的问题是：你有一个前端应用程序，对吧？你有一个银行应用，比如银行应用程序，对吧？你的银行应用需要进行一笔交易或别的什么，对吧？为什么银行应用不能直接与银行的数据库对话？为什么它不能直接说 SQL？我们以前就是这么做的。所有开发人员都知道这一点，对吧？
Assuming it's a SQL database. So why not just do that? Why does this app then speak to an API in Rails or Node.js or Python or whatever it is, right? And then we have an API. It speaks in http and json and you have an api and then this api things use an orm like you said right and then that orm then speaks to a database like the orm is like a translation layer so that you can translate like python concepts or node.js concepts or typescript concepts into sql if it's a sql database and then
假设它是一个 SQL 数据库。那为什么不直接那样做呢？为什么这个应用要跟 Rails、Node.js、Python 或其他什么语言编写的 API 对话，对吧？然后我们有了一个 API。它使用 HTTP 和 JSON 进行通信，你有一个 API，然后这个 API 中的东西使用了一个 ORM，就像你说的，对吧？然后那个 ORM 又跟数据库对话——ORM 就像是一个翻译层，以便你可以将 Python 概念、Node.js 概念或 TypeScript 概念翻译成 SQL（如果它是 SQL 数据库），然后
it runs against database but why do we have these layers in the middle? Is it worth having these layers in the middle rather than just telling developers to just use SQL? Right? To interact with it? But what's happening? And so, when we broke this down, we said that the hypothesis was
它针对数据库运行。但为什么我们在中间要有这些层？在中间有这些层是否值得，而不是直接告诉开发人员去使用 SQL？对吧？来与之交互？但到底是怎么回事呢？所以，当我们分解这个问题时，我们说我们的假设是
the only thing that is happening at the API layer, like, the only thing that is happening at the API layer, like the only two things that necessitate this API layer is one, a performance problem, which is that databases don't handle high concurrency really well. They're getting better, but they're still not able to handle
在 API 层唯一发生的事情——就像，在 API 层唯一发生的事情，就像唯一需要这个 API 层的两件事是：第一，性能问题，即数据库处理高并发的能力真的不是很好。它们正在变得越来越好，但它们仍然无法处理
like 100K, 200K kind of concurrent users. They prefer having 1000 concurrent connections, as opposed to 10,000 concurrent, like 20,000 concurrent HTTP users. Yeah, let me let me actually just, if you could bear with me, I'll dive into that a little bit, give a little detail for the audience. So, you know, when you have this API server, you know, it's handling tens of thousands of requests, maybe thousands of requests a second even, but it has a relatively small pool of database connections. And so it might be that a lot of those requests could be waiting for, you know, a spot in that pool, but that keeps your database from blowing up. Exactly, right?
比如 10 万、20 万这样的并发用户。它们更喜欢有 1000 个并发连接，而不是 10,000 个并发、比如 20,000 个并发的 HTTP 用户。是的，让我——其实如果能打扰你一下，我来深入探讨一下，为听众提供一些细节。所以，你知道，当你拥有这个 API 服务器时，它处理着成千上万的请求，甚至可能每秒数千个请求，但它只有一个相对较小的数据库连接池。因此，许多请求可能都在等待池中的一个空位，但这可以让你的数据库不至于崩溃。完全正确，对吧？
And you multiplex them, right? So you realize that a thousand of these requests are kind of requesting the same data, but you keep the connection open and you pipeline those concurrent requests over the same connection, right? Because databases like having, they like having long connections that are open for a long time
而你可以对它们进行多路复用（multiplex），对吧？所以你意识到这些请求中有上千个是在请求相同的数据，但你保持连接打开，并通过同一个连接流水线式地处理这些并发请求，对吧？因为数据库喜欢这样做，它们喜欢拥有长期保持打开的连接，
and they do a lot of optimizations with that. They don't like it when you frequently disconnect and reconnect and do things. It kind of breaks some of the optimizations and stuff that they have, right? So that pipelining and preparing those statements and pre-compiling query plans and everything works better when you have a long connection that lasts as opposed to short connections that come and go, come and go, which is the more mobile traffic, right? And so you have this layer in the middle. And I think the second critical reason
并且它们会利用这一点做很多优化。它们不喜欢你频繁地断开连接、重新连接以及做各种事情。这会破坏它们的一些优化等，对吧？所以这种流水线化、预处理这些语句以及预编译查询计划，在拥有一个持久的长连接时效果更好，而不是那些来来去去、短暂消失的短连接，这正是移动端流量的特点，对吧？所以你在中间有了这一层。我想这是第二个关键原因。
behind that API server is security or authorization, which is that things and products that are running can't access those data systems directly because the business model of applications on the internet is based around centralized data and centralized logic. That's the business model of the internet, right? Of like web 2.0, right? Let's not do crypto. But like the business model for the internet is that I have some centralized data and logic as a company and I'm going to make that available and I'm going to be the trusted source of the centralized data
API 服务器的背后是安全或授权，也就是说正在运行的程序和产品不能直接访问这些数据系统，因为互联网上应用程序的商业模式是围绕集中式数据和集中式逻辑构建的。这就是互联网的商业模式，对吧？也就是 Web 2.0 的商业模式，对吧？我们先不谈加密货币。但互联网的商业模式是，作为一家公司，我拥有一些集中式的数据和逻辑，我要把这些数据和逻辑开放出来，并且我要成为这个集中式数据的受信任来源。
and I'm going to make it available to all these users who are running in insecure private contexts, right? Like your device is your phone. You technically, even if you don't like understand the machine, that code is yours. It's not running in the security context of the company. So your bank app, the code is insecure because the code is running with you.
我要把它提供给所有这些运行在不安全私有环境中的用户，对吧？就像你的设备就是你的手机。从技术上讲，即使你不太懂这台机器，那段代码也是你的。它不是在公司的安全上下文中运行的。所以你的银行应用，它的代码是不安全的，因为代码是和你一起运行的。
That has to communicate and run a transaction or do a thing. But that is centralized data, right? So that is centralized logic. So you're crossing the security boundary, right? You're crossing this boundary of like, somebody is requesting a thing and we don't trust them. You're converting that into an action that is trusted and saying, yep, we understand this action and we can go execute this action.
它必须进行通信并运行交易或执行某项操作。但那是集中式数据，对吧？所以那是集中式逻辑。因此，你正在跨越安全边界，对吧？你正在跨越这样一个边界：有人在请求某个东西，而我们不信任他们。你将这个请求转化为一个受信任的操作，并说：“是的，我们理解这个操作，我们可以去执行这个操作。”
So that authorization problem, and if you break down what authorization is, it's input validation. Somebody submitted a form. Is this form correct data? You don't trust it because it's coming from a form. Somebody is like filling in some junk there, right? Or somebody's being malicious.
所以那个授权问题，如果你剖析一下什么是授权，它其实就是输入验证。有人提交了一个表单。这个表单的数据正确吗？你不能信任它，因为它是通过表单提交的。有人可能会在里面填一些垃圾信息，对吧？或者有人心怀恶意。
So you don't trust that input. So you validate it. Give an example here. Like if you're listening at your computer, don't do this if you're in your car and you're unless you're at a red light or something, but actually, I don't know if you can do this on mobile anyways. Anyways, if you're, if you're at your computer and you're listening to the show, you can go to any website right now. You can right click on
所以你不能相信那个输入。因此你需要对其进行验证。这里举个例子。如果你正在电脑前听节目，在车里的话就别这么做了——除非你在红灯前或者什么的，不过实际上，我也不知道你在手机上能不能这么做。总之，如果你在电脑前并且正在听这个节目，你现在可以访问任何网站。你可以右键点击
anything and you can, there's a button called inspect and it'll take you to the code and you can go in and change it. Like you want to make, you want to make Twitter, you know, my Twitter, you could just go in now it won't show for anyone else, but for you, it'll show. And you can even change what you send to Twitter or any, any website. Like you can send it literally anything you want. And so it's, it's completely, you know, in your control, it's your code. And, and so that's the, that's the problem is if you have now full access to the database, you could say, oh, hey, Chase Bank, I have a million dollars now. Exactly. Give me everybody's data and whatnot.
任何东西，里面有一个叫“检查”（inspect）的按钮，它会带你去看代码，然后你就可以进去修改它。比如你想把 Twitter 改成……你知道的，改成“我的 Twitter”，你现在就可以进去改，虽然别人看不到，但对你来说是能看到的。你甚至可以改变你发送给 Twitter 或任何网站的内容。你可以发送任何你字面意思上想要的东西。所以，这完全在你的控制之中，这是你的代码。因此，问题就在于，如果你现在对数据库拥有完全的访问权限，你就可以说：“哦，嘿，大通银行（Chase Bank），我现在有一百万美元了。”没错。给我每个人的数据之类的。
So I remember one of those initial demos that we used to do to help people understand websites. It's like you open up a popular website and then you inspect element and you open up the HTML and then you'd go to like, you'd inspect element, and you'd open up the HTML, and then you'd go delete that HTML node. And suddenly the website in front of you would change and you'd be like, oh, the logo just disappeared. How did that happen? And then you're like, well, this is what it is, right? It's the code is sent to you. And you're running the code in your context. And it's your machine, it's your machine. This code is now running with your security context. And you can own it and you can change it and you can do all sorts of wacko things with it. And so that
所以我记得我们以前用过的一个最初的演示，是用来帮助人们理解网站的。就像你打开一个热门网站，然后检查元素，打开 HTML，然后你会去……检查元素，打开 HTML，然后删除那个 HTML 节点。突然之间，你面前的网站就变了，你会想：“哦，标志刚刚消失了。这是怎么发生的？”然后你会想：“哦，原来是这样，对吧？代码被发送到了你这里。你在你的上下文中运行这些代码。这是你的机器，这是你的机器。现在这段代码正在你的安全上下文中运行。你可以掌控它，可以修改它，还可以用它做各种稀奇古怪的事情。”所以
this API layer is essentially, at its core, solving just two problems. It's solving this problem of arbitrating performance. And performance is subtle. It's this concurrency issue. You have speed of light issues. Your centralized data base is in the u.s and then you have um users in china
这个 API 层本质上核心只解决了两个问题。它解决的是仲裁性能的问题。而且性能问题很微妙。这是一个并发问题。你会遇到光速问题。你的集中式数据库在美国，而你
and they're like what i'm like the speed of light rtt itself is about like 180 milliseconds right across the world twice and you're like i mean it feels laggy right so you want to cache things that are closer to your users and stuff like that. There's like physics problems where you're still kind of restricted by this experience that you can have with a system. And so you have these kinds
的用户在中国，
of performance issues that you need to solve for. That's kind of one category. And the second category is essentially security and authorization validation. But in our minds and our kind of hypothesis for building the company was saying, these
你需要解决这些性能问题。这算是一类问题。第二类问题本质上是安全和授权验证。但在我们心里，以及我们当初建立这家公司的假设来看，我们认为，
are the only two problems that need to be solved. Everything else is just legacy. Everything else is people just doing things because they just do things. Yeah, I mean, that was one of the beauties behind the beautiful things about things like Next.js, where you're writing your front end back end server. So letters, but someone could just say, oh, I'm going to post a new username API with a two-letter username. So, okay, now on the server, I have to say, okay, did this person disable the two, the three-letter check on their browser? And so the cool thing about things like Next is, you know, you would have the same logic on front-end and like the same, literally the same code on front end and back end, but on the back end, no one could mess with it. But, but it's even
这些就是需要解决的仅有的两个问题。其他一切都只是遗留问题。其他一切都只是人们习以为常、墨守成规的做法。是的，我的意思是，这就是像 Next.js 这样的一些技术背后美妙的地方之一，在那里你编写的是前端后端一体的服务器。比如字母，但有人可能会说：“哦，我要用一个两字母的用户名来发布一个新的用户名 API。”所以，好吧，现在在服务器上，我必须说：“好吧，这个人是不是在他们的浏览器上禁用了两字母、三字母的检查？”所以像 Next 这样的技术很酷的一点是，你知道的，你可以在前端和后端使用相同的逻辑，甚至是字面上完全相同的代码，但在后端，没有人可以篡改它。但是，即使
with something like that, it's still a hassle that you have to think about everything twice. Yep, exactly. Right. And you still have to think about it twice. And then when you think about like, where's my security rule, is it enforced in the right place and whatnot. Right. And so the, the idea then was to say, if want to automate api development and we want to automate this middle layer so that people can kind of go build products um including things like you know build it with next.js or build it serverless or build it with uh build apps right uh go ahead and do that and use these managed data services that are continuously getting better but this middle piece should just be automated. It should just be an implementation detail.
有类似这样的东西，你仍然需要把每件事考虑两遍，这还是很麻烦。是的，完全正确。没错。你仍然需要考虑两遍。然后当你考虑到诸如“我的安全规则在哪里，它是否在正确的地方强制执行”之类的问题时。没错。所以当时的构想是，如果我们想要自动化 API 开发，并且想要自动化这个中间层，以便人们能够构建产品——包括诸如用 Next.js 构建、无服务器（serverless）构建，或者构建应用——去吧，尽管去做，并且使用那些不断变得更好的托管数据服务，但中间这部分应该直接被自动化。它应该只是一种实现细节。
It should be magic that exists. It's expected. It's an expected part of your infrastructure. And so what we did was we built an engine where if you can provide like a semantic model of how your data models become domain models, right? So you say that here's a user table uh inside this database and here's documents inside that database and together they become a user model and a document model like they convert into logical models that you have that represent your domain so if you can do the modeling and do
它应该是一个存在的魔法。它是理所当然的。它是你基础设施中理所当然的一部分。所以我们做的是，我们构建了一个引擎，如果你能提供一个语义模型，说明你的数据模型是如何变成领域模型的，对吧？比如你在这个数据库里面说“这里有一个用户表”，这里面有“文档”，它们组合在一起就成了一个用户模型和一个文档模型——它们转化为你拥有的、代表你业务领域的逻辑模型。所以如果你能进行建模并完成
each of these models you can attach all the authorization rules that you'd ever need whether it's input validation what who can access them, really complicated rules. Like you can say, allow accessing a document if it's public, or if the current user is a collaborator, or if the current user is a family member of whoever owns the document, right? And there's hierarchical rules, there's all kinds of stuff, then certain fields are hidden and masked, whatever, right? Like it's all just, we call it authorization. So if we have a nice system to model and to authorize those models,
每一个模型，你就可以附加你可能需要的所有的授权规则，无论是输入验证、谁可以访问它们，还是非常复杂的规则。比如你可以说，如果文档是公开的，或者当前用户是协作者，或者当前用户是文档所有者的家庭成员，就允许访问文档，对吧？这里有层级规则，有各种各样的东西，然后某些字段被隐藏和屏蔽，诸如此类，对吧？这全部都是——我们称之为授权。因此，如果我们有一个很好的系统来对这些模型进行建模和授权，
then we can just create the API automatically. This is the only domain-specific work that needs to be done. That's all you need to do. Nothing else should be written by hand, right? If we have this information about what your models are and how those models are secured, then we can generate the API that has pagination and the ability to fetch from multiple sources in one shot, the ability to write data securely, the ability to read data securely, cache it, have HTTP level
我们就可以自动创建 API。这是唯一需要完成的领域特定工作。这就是你需要做的全部。其他任何东西都不应该手写，对吧？如果我们拥有关于你的模型是什么以及这些模型是如何被保护的信息，那么我们就可以生成具备以下功能的 API：支持分页、能够一次性从多个来源获取数据、能够安全地写入数据、能够安全地读取数据、进行缓存、实现 HTTP 级别的
concurrency, do all kinds of things that you do by hand. But we can automate a whole chunk of that by saying that the user just needs to work at this meta layer, right? This domain layer. You think in models and you think about your domain and you don't do anything else. And so we built our own JSON API that does this. So we have like a metadata language, a domain specific language, a DSL, which is in JSON essentially. So we have like a metadata language, a domain-specific language, a DSL, which is in JSON, essentially. So it's like a JSON configuration. And in this JSON configuration,
并发，以及完成各种你通常需要手写的事情。但我们可以通过让用户只需在这个元层——这个领域层工作，来自动化其中很大一部分。你用模型思考，你思考你的领域，而不需要做任何其他事情。所以我们构建了自己的 JSON API 来实现这一点。所以我们有一种元数据语言、一种领域特定语言（DSL），它本质上是用 JSON 编写的。所以我们有一种元数据语言、一种领域特定语言（DSL），它本质上是用 JSON 编写的。所以它就像是一个 JSON 配置。在这个 JSON 配置中，
you provide the models and you provide authorization rules of those models. And you submit that to the Hasura engine. And the Hasura engine essentially just becomes the API. So instead of you writing code and then compiling that
你提供模型，并提供这些模型的授权规则。然后你将该配置提交给 Hasura 引擎。Hasura 引擎本质上就变成了 API。因此，你不再需要编写代码然后进行编译，
or running that inside an app server, Hustler is an existing app server that's already running, right? And then you just give it the configuration of your domain, the description of your domain and the models, the concrete description of your domains and models, and bam, we become the API. And we launched this in 2018. Open source became really popular. I think we went from like 2 million to 100 million to like a billion downloads over like the next few years.
或者在应用服务器中运行它，Hasura 是一个已经在大力运行的现有应用服务器，对吧？然后你只需要把你的领域配置、你的领域和模型的描述、具体描述传给它，砰，我们就变成了 API。我们在 2018 年推出了这个产品。开源项目变得非常受欢迎。我想在接下来的几年里，我们的下载量从大约 200 万增长到 1 亿，再到大约 10 亿。
And that kind of brings us to today. Yeah, this is awesome. So I definitely want to know more about the authorization piece. But let's start from the foundation here. So what you were talking about, you know, you have either a website or a mobile app, and that app, you know, transfers information to a backend server. And with something like Hasura, that backend server is auto-generated, but it's still running so that it can, you know, make queries with an elevated permission, right? And so it's talking to the database. So, you know,
这就把我们带到了今天。是的，这太棒了。所以我非常想了解更多关于授权的部分。但让我们从这里的基石开始。所以你刚才谈到的，你知道的，你要么有一个网站，要么有一个移动应用，然后那个应用（你知道的）将信息传输到后端服务器。在使用像 Hasura 这样的技术时，那个后端服务器是自动生成的，但它仍在运行，这样它就可以（你知道的）以提升的权限进行查询，对吧？所以它在与数据库对话。所以，（你知道的）
imagine a sort of mental model where you have front end, you have your front end server, and then you have your database. And you might even have back end servers if they have to do some complex thing like image processing or something like that. So that gap between the front end and the front end server, that gap is covered through HTTP calls. So you make an HTTP request, say, log in, or you make HTTP requests, say, get my profile. And if you're doing something with traditional REST, the way those look is actually not that different from the way a website works.
想象一下这样一种心理模型：你有前端，你有前端服务器，然后你有数据库。如果它们必须做一些复杂的事情（比如图像处理或类似的事情），你甚至可能还会有后端服务器。前端和前端服务器之间的那个间隙，是通过 HTTP 调用来弥补的。所以你会发出一个 HTTP 请求，比如登录，或者发出一个 HTTP 请求，比如获取我的个人资料。如果你用的是传统的 REST，这些请求的外观实际上与网站的工作方式没有太大区别。
Like you go to google.com slash search, and what you're going to get back is some HTML content. And your browser knows to render that as a website. Yeah, if you go to google.com slash and I'm making this up, but slash API slash, you know, foobar.json, then your browser is going to get some automated, you know, some some machine intended content. And it's going to render it again, like maybe you'll get this, depending on your browser, you might get this nice UI where you can fold parts of the JSON and stuff, but you're effectively getting stuff that's meant for a machine. And so then, you know, putting it all together, when you go to google.com slash search, you know, that HTML and that
就像你访问 google.com/search 一样，你将要返回的是一些 HTML 内容。你的浏览器知道将其渲染为一个网站。是的，如果你访问 google.com/——我是随便编的——/api/foobar.json，那么你的浏览器将会得到一些自动化的（你知道的）、面向机器的内容。然后它会再次渲染它，也许你会得到这个，取决于你的浏览器，你可能会得到一个很好的用户界面，你可以在其中折叠 JSON 的某些部分之类的，但你实际上得到的是专门为机器准备的东西。然后，（你知道的）把所有这些结合起来，当你访问 google.com/search 时，你知道的，那个 HTML 和那个
JavaScript will now have commands to get other websites. And those other websites are enriching that user interface with more data. So maybe the latest weather or something comes in through a separate call. And you don't see all you can see all of those calls, you know, if you go to the developer mode. But by default, you know, you're only seeing that main website just under the hood. It's making all of these calls. And so, you know, REST is the simplest.
JavaScript 现在将包含用于获取其他网站的命令。而那些其他的网站正在用更多的数据丰富该用户界面。所以最新的天气信息或类似的内容可能会通过单独的调用传进来。你看不到所有这些调用，（你知道的）如果你进入开发者模式的话。但在默认情况下，（你知道的）你只看到那个主要的网站，而在底层，它正在进行所有这些调用。所以，（你知道的）REST 是最简单的。
And is REST an acronym? I think it is, right? Yeah, I think it's a representational state transfer, I think. Oh, look at you. Nice. So, yeah, so REST is the sort of like canonical, like the version 1.0 way of doing this. And basically, you have query parameters. And this is just like a regular website.
REST 是一个首字母缩写吗？我想是的，对吧？是的，我想它是表述性状态转移（Representational State Transfer），我想是的。哦，瞧瞧你。不错。所以，是的，REST 是这种做法的典型代表，也就是 1.0 版本的做法。基本上，你有查询参数。这就像一个常规的网站一样。
You do question mark, A equals B, C equals D, E equals F. You also have a post body. So if you're making a post HTTP request, you could put a bunch of JSON or XML or whatever you want in the body, YAML if you want. That goes to a server. That server now has to take the query and the body of your request, figure out what you intend to do there, And then it can return, you know, some arbitrary information. So what is GraphQL? Why is it invented? You know,
你输入问号，A 等于 B，C 等于 D，E 等于 F。你还有一个 POST 请求体。因此，如果你在发送 POST HTTP 请求，你可以在请求体中放入一堆 JSON 或 XML 或任何你想要的东西，如果你愿意的话也可以是 YAML。这会发送到一个服务器。该服务器现在必须获取你请求中的查询和请求体，弄清楚你在那里打算做什么，然后它就可以返回（你知道的）一些任意的信息。那么，什么是 GraphQL？为什么要发明它？（你知道的）
what's wrong with REST? You know, what is it doing, doing better than all of that? Yeah, yeah, absolutely spot on, right. And then when you can kind of just build on top of that, remember when you mentioned that, like when you have like a google search page or something that comes in you do have data sometimes coming in not just from the primary google server that surfaces like the search results but you have like that weather information snippet thing coming in right and you have like you have other pieces of information that are also required for that one page that you're viewing right and so what started happening was that as mobile applications became more complicated, we wanted to do more.
REST 有什么毛病？（你知道的）它比所有那些东西做得好的地方在哪里？是的，完全说得对，对吧。然后，当你可以在此基础上进行构建时，还记得你刚才提到过，就像当你有一个谷歌搜索页面或类似的东西加载进来时，你有时不仅会获得来自主谷歌服务器的数据（该服务器提供搜索结果），还会获得类似天气信息片段之类的内容，对吧？你会获得其他一些信息，而这些信息也是你正在浏览的那个单一页面所必需的，对吧？所以开始发生的情况是，随着移动应用变得越来越复杂，我们想要做更多的事情。
We had the opportunity to have a richer experience for a user. And the user could see more, right, on their screen and they could interact with it more. And when they wanted to see that information, right, you'd realize that you have to now hit multiple different machines and services and data sources to fetch that data, right?
我们有机会为用户提供更丰富的体验。用户可以在屏幕上看到更多内容（对吧），并且可以与它进行更多的互动。当他们想要查看这些信息时（对吧），你会意识到你现在必须访问多个不同的机器、服务和数据源来获取该数据，对吧？
You are rendering a profile page. So you want to show the account information, but you also want to show the recent orders that this person has made, which might come from different services, right? Different API services or different data sources that are storing that information. Because remember, we're not in a place
你正在渲染一个个人资料页面。所以你想显示账户信息，但你也想显示这个人最近下的订单，而这些订单可能来自不同的服务，对吧？不同的 API 服务或存储该信息的不同数据源。因为记住，我们并不是处在一个
where we can store all of that data onto one single database, right? We are storing that in multiple sources of data. There's multiple ways of interacting with, there's different ways of interacting with these different sources of data and whatnot, right? And so when you're seeing that profile page on an e-commerce website, you're seeing that account information coming from one place, you're seeing a recent order activity coming in from one place, you're seeing your last five addresses, right? Saved cards, whatever.
可以将所有这些数据存储到单个数据库中的地方，对吧？我们将其存储在多个数据源中。有多种与这些不同数据源进行交互的方式，对吧？所以当你在一个电商网站上看到那个个人资料页面时，你会看到账户信息来自一个地方，你会看到最近的订单活动来自一个地方，你会看到你的最后五个地址（对吧）、保存的卡片等等。
These are all like different sources of data that are then being unified into one thing. So what started happening was that people started getting frustrated with saying, I'm having to make too many API calls to fetch this information. And this frustration caused, like showed up in two ways right the first frustration was as a developer when you were like i can have one gigantic api con that fetches everything right like i'll build an api server that does this work for me it goes and fetches all of the data in one shot and then returns this giant thing to me right and then this frustration showed up as like every time i want a
这些都是不同的数据源，然后它们被统一成一个东西。所以开始发生的情况是，人们开始感到沮丧，他们说：“我不得不进行太多的 API 调用来获取这些信息。”这种沮丧导致了——以两种方式表现出来，对吧？第一种沮丧是，作为一个开发者，当你觉得“我可以拥有一个巨大的 API 端点来获取所有东西”时——比如我会构建一个为我做这项工作的 API 服务器，它去一次性获取所有数据，然后把这个巨大的东西返回给我，对吧？然后这种沮丧表现为：每次我想要
different slice of data it's painful so i'm on a mobile screen i want to show you id and name on the page and i'm on a web screen i want to show you id name age email address right so i want to show you a different slice of data because if i show you less data i can transfer it faster cheaper bandwidth cheaper battery faster experience or if i want to show it on your desktop screen, you typically have like a better internet connection, your computer is more powerful, you have more real estate, you can show more data, right? Now, as a developer, when I'm building these products, every time I have a different slice of the same data that I want to show somebody has to go build
不同切片的数据时，这都很痛苦。所以我在手机屏幕上，我想在页面上显示用户 ID 和姓名；而在网页屏幕上，我想显示用户 ID、姓名、年龄和电子邮件地址。所以我想要展示不同切片的数据，因为如果我展示较少的数据，我就可以更快、更便宜地传输它——带宽更便宜、耗电量更少、体验更快；或者如果我想在你的桌面屏幕上展示它，你通常拥有更好的互联网连接，你的计算机更强大，你有更多的屏幕空间，你可以展示更多的数据，对吧？现在，作为一个开发者，当我构建这些产品时，每次我想要向某人展示相同数据的不同切片时，都必须去构建
a new API somebody has to build an API for five fields for 100 fields for 50 fields it's a pain like you have to build new API endpoints for each shape of your data that you want right that was kind of one frustration right the second piece that showed up then was when you're integrating multiple API calls into the building experience, it sucks. It really feels, it's terrible. It's like the worst part of building the product is integrating APIs, right? It's like, you just want to build the product. You don't want to integrate APIs because an API is asynchronous. So you fetch data, you have to wait for it. Then the screen loads up. Yep, and you have to do something while you're waiting, you have to make the little loading spinner
一个新的 API。总得有人为一个字段、100 个字段、50 个字段构建 API，这太痛苦了。对于你想要的每一种数据形态，你都必须构建新的 API 端点，对吧？这算是一种沮丧，对吧？然后出现的第二个问题是，当你将多个 API 调用集成到构建体验中时，这太糟糕了。感觉真的很差。集成 API 是构建产品中最糟糕的部分，对吧？就像，你只想构建产品。你不想集成 API，因为 API 是异步的。所以你获取数据，你必须等待。然后屏幕加载出来。是的，而且你必须在等待时做点什么，你必须做一个小型的加载动画
and everything. Yeah, exactly. The only thing worse than an API call is multiple API calls. It's the only thing worse than having one API call on the thing that you want to build. You're like, goddammit, there's 50 now on this page, right? And so, it's very frustrating.
以及所有这些。是的，完全正确。唯一比 API 调用更糟糕的事情就是多个 API 调用。这是你想构建的东西中拥有一个 API 带来的唯一更糟糕的事情。你会想：“天哪，现在这个页面上有 50 个了，对吧？”所以，这非常令人沮丧。
And so, a bunch of people tried many different ways to address this issue right yeah there was there was meteor that was a thing remember meteor js correct meteor was a thing that tried to unify it around like a mongo thing that the apollo folks did then we had i think the approach that was trying to create this back-end for front-end type situation was falcor by the netflix folks microsoft had something like odata there's a whole bunch of like microsoft sap there's a whole bunch of approaches and then the facebook folks created a specification for something called graphql which was essentially a more structured way it used a subset of the same concepts that we had in rust so you have like a
因此，许多人尝试了许多不同的方法来解决这个问题，对吧？是的，曾经有过 Meteor，那是个东西，还记得 Meteor.js 吗？没错，Meteor 曾是一个试图围绕类似 Mongo 的东西进行整合的东西，然后是 Apollo 团队做的东西。接着我们有——我认为试图创造这种“前端后端”（BFF）类型情况的方法是 Netflix 团队的 Falcor，微软有类似于 OData 的东西，微软和 SAP 有一大堆类似的方法，然后 Facebook 团队创造了一种名为 GraphQL 的规范，它本质上是一种结构化的方法，它使用了我们在 REST 中拥有的一些相同概念的子集。所以你有一个
the intention is to say that you have a post method on a HTTP endpoint, but the post method now sends a query, a richer query that describes all of the things that you want. And the API server is now a more capable API server that can understand this query and fetch data from multiple
意图是说，你在一个 HTTP 端点上有一个 POST 方法，但这个 POST 方法现在发送一个查询，一个描述你想要的所有东西的更丰富的查询。而 API 服务器现在是一个更有能力的 API 服务器，它可以理解这个查询，并根据需要从多个
places as required and then return that. So you're giving more control to the product builders and saying, you tell us what you want, and we'll fetch it. So you tell us if you want a user and just the ID name, that's fine too. But you tell us that you want the user, ID name, last five addresses, last five orders, that's fine too.
地方获取数据，然后将其返回。所以你把更多的控制权交给了产品构建者，并说：“你告诉我们你想要什么，我们就会去获取它。”所以你告诉我们你是否想要一个用户，并且只需要 ID 和姓名，那也没问题。但你告诉我们你想要用户、ID、姓名、最后五个地址、最后五个订单，那也没问题。
But all you have to do is send us one query on the API server, right? Kind of like a SQL for APIs, right? You don't go to a database and then you don't go to the database and you're like, hey, so give me one row from that table. Yeah, now give me one row here.
但你所要做的就是向 API 服务器发送一个查询，对吧？有点像面向 API 的 SQL，对吧？你不会去访问数据库，然后说：“嘿，给我那张表里的一行。”“好吧，现在给我这里的一行。”
And now do that. And now you don't do that. You don't restfully interact with the database, right? You interact in a richer way like SQL. GraphQL brings that to the API layer, right? You're having a rich interaction with your APIs. You're fetching the slices of data that you want. And that kind of was the genesis of GraphQL brings that to the API layer, right? You're having a rich interaction with your APIs. You're fetching the slices of data that you want. And that kind of was the genesis of GraphQL.
“现在做那个。”你不会那样做。你不会以 RESTful 的方式与数据库交互，对吧？你以一种更丰富的方式交互，就像 SQL 一样。GraphQL 把这一点带到了 API 层，对吧？你正在与你的 API 进行丰富的交互。你正在获取你想要的数据切片。这差不多就是 GraphQL 的起源。
And it became an amazing API to consume for people who are building products. It was a lot more intuitive. I had to do slightly lesser work than integrating multiple endpoints. And I say slightly mildly, you had to do a lot lesser work when you had to integrate multiple endpoints.
对于构建产品的人来说，它成了一个令人惊叹的、可以消费的 API。它直观得多。与集成多个端点相比，我需要做的工作稍微少了一点。我说的“稍微”是温和的，当你必须集成多个端点时，你实际上需要做的工作要少得多。
And the query language felt nicer. It felt like it's the part of the JSON that I want, right? So that's kind of what GraphQL is like. It's a specification. It's exactly like SQL is a spec or REST is a spec or gRPC is a spec. So it's just a spec. And that's what GraphQL was. Yeah, that makes sense.
而且查询语言感觉更好。它感觉就像是我想要的 JSON 的一部分，对吧？所以这就是 GraphQL 的样子。它是一个规范。它完全就像 SQL 是一个规范，REST 是一个规范，或者 gRPC 是一个规范一样。所以它只是一个规范。这就是 GraphQL 的本质。是的，这讲得通。
So I was trying to tie back to Husserl here. is a spec. So it's just a spec. And that's what GraphQL was. Yeah, that makes sense. So trying to tie back to Husserl here. So with the rest, you had a really good point, which is, I want to get my redacted profile or my profile with just my name, or I want to get my profile with my age. If I want to do this in one call, then I can have a query parameter that says return age, true or false. If it's true, then I get the age. And then if you take this to its logical limit, then it's like of everything I could return, you know, in my request, I say, yes, give me the age. Yes. Give me the name. Yes. Give me the profile. No, don't give me the long description. And so taken to its logical limit,
所以我想把它和 Hasura 联系起来。它只是一个规范。这就是 GraphQL 的本质。是的，这讲得通。所以试着把它和 Hasura 联系起来。所以在 REST 中，你有一个非常好的观点，那就是：我想获取我被脱敏的个人资料，或者只想获取带有我姓名的个人资料，或者我想获取带有我年龄的个人资料。如果我想在一次调用中做到这一点，那么我可以有一个查询参数，规定返回年龄为 true 或 false。如果是 true，那么我就能得到年龄。然后，如果你把这一点推导到它的逻辑极限，那么它就变成：在我请求中可以返回的所有内容中，你知道的，我说：是的，把年龄给我。是的。把姓名给我。是的。把个人资料给我。不，不要把冗长的描述给我。所以推导到它的逻辑极限，
you end up with something like GraphQL where it's like, here's the things I want to return, and then everything else I don't want to return by definition. Exactly, exactly. And then, you know, tying it back to authorization, the thing you have to really watch out for is, if you're not careful, you might be able to say things like, give me Patrick's bank account. And so, and so like with rest, you know, because you're doing it, it's almost like the, you've seen this argument since assembly, like there were those people way back in the day who said, Oh, you know, with assembly, I have all this extra control because I'm doing all this extra work. And any of that's true, but you pay for it in efficiency. But yeah, with, with rest, it's like like you clearly see, you know, if there's an API call that
你最终会得到类似 GraphQL 的东西，就像是：这些是我想要返回的东西，然后根据定义，其他所有东西我都不想返回。精确，精确。然后，你知道的，把它和授权联系起来，你真正需要当心的是：如果你不够小心，你可能会说出这样的话：“把帕特里克的银行账户给我。”所以，所以在使用 REST 时，你知道的，因为你在这样做，它几乎就像是——你从汇编语言时代就见过这种争论——早期有那些人说：“哦，你知道吗，通过汇编语言，我拥有所有这些额外的控制权，因为我做了所有这些额外的工作。”这些话全都是真的，但你付出了效率的代价。但是，是的，在使用 REST 时，就像
says, you know, give bank account, you know, you're begged to wonder like, okay, am I making sure I'm not getting everyone's bank account? But with GraphQL, you can end up with a blind spot where you accidentally allow someone to get someone else's information. Exactly right. I think you have to be very careful in how you're building a GraphQL because with great power comes great responsibility, right? Like you gave more power to the front-end developers
你能清楚地看到（你知道的），如果有一个 API 调用说：“给出银行账户”（你知道的），你会不禁想：“好吧，我有确保自己没有拿到所有人的银行账户吗？”但在使用 GraphQL 时，你可能会陷入一个盲区，不小心允许某人获取其他人的信息。完全正确。我认为你在构建 GraphQL 时必须非常小心，因为能力越大，责任越大，对吧？就像你赋予了前端开发人员
or product developers, and then now you're like, whoops, somebody's gone to absorb the complexity or the increase in our footprint of being, if you're able to serve more, then you have to make sure that all the ways that this data is being served is secure. In REST, you control that like as an API builder, like you decide, well sure that all the ways that this data is being secured. In REST, you control
或产品开发人员更多的权力，然后现在你会想：“哎呀，有人去吸收了复杂性，或者吸收了我们作为服务器能够服务更多的足迹的增加，那么你必须确保所有这些提供数据的方式都是安全的。”在 REST 中，作为 API 构建者，你可以控制这一点，比如你决定——确保所有这些提供数据的方式都是安全的。在 REST 中，你进行控制
that as an API builder. You decide there's five API calls. That's all you get. And so for these five, I'm going to manually make sure that each of them is secure. But with GraphQL, the space is infinite. You can say, I want a little bit of this and a little bit of that and then together. And I want
作为 API 构建者。你决定有五个 API 端点。这就是你所拥有的全部。所以对于这五个端点，我将手动确保它们中的每一个都是安全的。但对于 GraphQL 来说，空间是无限的。你可以说：我想要一点这个，一点那个，然后把它们组合起来。我想要
this and this and that, like A, B and C together, but bits of A and bits of B. you're like fetching the data in a bunch of different ways right and so the surface area is larger and the way that we think about it is everything should be model driven we should separate the idea of the api protocol from the idea of the model because in your domain what is important is the models that you have and the authorization rules are attached of the model. Because in your domain, what is important is the models that you have and the authorization rules are attached to the model. It is independent of what API, like what protocol is being used
这个、这个和那个，就像把 A、B 和 C 组合在一起，但只要 A 的一部分和 B 的一部分。你会发现你正在用各种不同的方式获取数据，对吧？所以攻击面更大了，而我们思考这个问题的方式是：一切都应该由模型驱动。我们应该将 API 协议的概念与模型的概念分开，因为在你的领域中，重要的是你拥有的模型，以及附加在模型上的授权规则。因为在你的领域中，重要的是你拥有的模型，以及附加在模型上的授权规则。它独立于使用什么 API、
to interact with that model, right? So if I have a model and you have REST APIs to do CRUD or you have a GraphQL API to query and subscribe and mutate, it doesn't matter. The point is that the model has a description of what it is and what its fields are. And its authorization policies have a description of what valid input for this model is or what valid ways to read it are for different kinds of users and roles and what should be redacted and what should be masked or what should be encrypted, whatever, right?
什么协议来与该模型进行交互，对吧？所以如果我有一个模型，而你有用于执行 CRUD 的 REST API，或者你有用于查询、订阅和突变的 GraphQL API，这都无所谓。关键是，模型有一个关于它是什么以及它的字段是什么的描述。它的授权策略有一个关于这个模型的有效输入是什么，或者对于不同类型的用户和角色有哪些有效的读取方式，什么应该被脱敏、什么应该被掩码或者什么应该被加密等等的描述，对吧？
Like all of that is data associated with the model. Because once you put that close to the model that's where your business is so now when somebody wants to go review and be like what what went wrong with like our users that we like leak information or whatever you don't actually care about graphql or rest or grpc or mq2 whatever right like that doesn't matter what you go do is you look at your model and you're like hmm i see what went wrong. Or yep, I'm guaranteed that this actually works because my security rules here are okay. As long as these security rules are okay, who cares about what the API does? I can solve that problem at a different way. Yeah. So in a way, REST can create this sort of landmine. For example, you might say,
所有这些都是与模型相关联的数据。因为一旦你把它放在靠近模型的地方——那是你的业务所在的地方——所以现在当有人想要去审查并想弄清楚“我们的用户泄露了信息或其他什么，到底是哪里出了问题”时，你其实并不关心 GraphQL、REST、gRPC 或 MQ2 等等，对吧？那不重要。你要做的是查看你的模型，然后你会想：“嗯，我知道哪里出错了。”或者“是的，我保证这确实行得通，因为我这里的安全规则没问题。”只要这些安全规则没问题，谁在乎 API 做什么呢？我可以用另一种方式解决这个问题。是的。所以在某种程度上，REST 会制造这种地雷。例如，你会说：
get my bank account balance. And in my bank account balance REST call, I check to make sure that I'm me and I'm not getting someone else's balance. Then someone else comes along and says, get me my 10 most recent transactions. If he doesn't have that same logic, now you've exposed a hole. And so if you have 100 REST APIs, all 100 need to share. And so you might as well just put this in a different layer to begin with, right? Exactly, right? You might as well just do all of this at the model level. Because with REST, what happens is that because the surface area is so small,
获取我的银行账户余额。而在我的银行账户余额 REST 调用中，我检查以确保我是我自己，并且我没有获取别人的余额。然后另一个人走过来，说：获取我最近的 10 笔交易。如果他没有相同的逻辑，你现在就暴露了一个漏洞。因此，如果你有 100 个 REST API，这 100 个 API 都需要共享。所以你不如一开始就把这放在一个不同的层里，对吧？完全正确，对吧？你不如直接在模型层完成所有这些工作。因为在 REST 中，情况是这样的：由于攻击面如此之小，
you're tempted to put all of that in the controller logic, right? You say, oh, you know, I only have five API endpoints. Why don't I secure each of them manually, right? And then before you know it, you're screwed because like the business keeps evolving and growing, right? And now you're like, nobody can even think about it. Nobody can even answer that question, right? If like a security person comes in
你很想把所有这些都放进控制器逻辑中，对吧？你会说：“哦，你知道吗，我只有五个 API 端点。为什么不手动保护它们中的每一个呢？”对吧？然后不知不觉中，你就搞砸了，因为业务在不断发展和壮大，对吧？现在你会觉得：“没有人能考虑周全了。”甚至没有人能回答那个问题，对吧？如果有安全人员进来，
or a product or business comes in and they're like, so how exactly are we securing this again? Nobody but a developer or two developers or like whoever wrote that old code, a new code, they all sit together, eyeball it, and then, then you know maybe they know what's going on yeah right right i'm surprised are there are there actually uh like things that sit in between sql and you know i mean i think asura has something are you sitting like, is Hasura built on top of a, you know, model authorization library? Is that a thing?
或者产品或业务人员进来，他们会问：“那么我们到底是怎么再次确保这一点的？”除了一个开发者、两个开发者，或者写过旧代码、新代码的那些人之外，没有人知道——他们都坐在一起，过目一下，然后——然后你才知道可能发生了什么，对吧？我感到惊讶的是，SQL 和（你知道的——我想 Hasura 有一些东西）之间真的有——你是坐在一层、Hasura 是建立在一个（你知道的）模型授权库之上的吗？有这种东西吗？
So we invented it basically for ourselves, right? So we invented a modeling system and a policy language that allowed this to happen, right? And so that's what we built for our product. We said, if we can capture models and we can capture authorization rules on these models, right? And we're releasing this model and authorization system as a framework. And we're releasing this as a specification for the community at large so that anybody can use this specification to build services, right? So Hosser uses this specification to provide an API.
所以我们基本上是为自己发明了它，对吧？所以我们发明了一个建模系统和一个策略语言，让这一切得以实现，对吧？这就是我们为产品构建的东西。我们说，如果我们能够捕获模型，并且能够在这些模型上捕获授权规则，对吧？我们将这个模型和授权系统作为框架进行发布。我们将其作为面向广大社区的规范进行发布，以便任何人都可以使用这个规范来构建服务，对吧？所以 Hasura 使用这个规范来提供 API。
But technically, you can imagine where if I have the system that describes models and authorization rules, technically I can generate Rails code from it or JavaScript code from it or Java code or.NET, doesn't matter, right? Because it's a concrete specification of what a model is and what the authorization rules are. So I can convert that concrete specification into any language or runtime that can then become the API. And so that's kind of what we're doing and something that we're going to talk about
但从技术上讲，你可以想象，如果我拥有这个描述模型和授权规则的系统，从技术上讲，我可以从中生成 Rails 代码、JavaScript 代码、Java 代码或 .NET，这都无所谓，对吧？因为它是关于模型是什么以及授权规则是什么的具体规范。所以我可以将该具体规范转换为任何可以变成 API 的语言或运行时。所以这正是我们正在做的事情，也是我们将在
at HasuraCon, where we're going to kind of release this internal spec that we have that makes this so easy. Because as a human, you just care about, here's the models, here's the authorization rules,
HasuraCon 上讨论的事情，我们将在这里发布我们拥有的这个内部规范，它使这一切变得如此简单。因为作为一个人，你关心的只是：这里是模型，这里是授权规则，
now go figure it out. I don't actually care about details. Right? Like, yeah, go write the Java code or whatever. Like, who cares? It's like, it's a shitty implementation that i don't care about right like let it just run but this is the concrete information that i care about and this is this is going to take you 80 90 95 percent of the way
现在去搞定它。我其实并不关心细节。对吧？就像，去写 Java 代码或其他什么。谁在乎呢？这就像是一个我不关心的垃圾实现，对吧？让它自己运行去吧，但这是我关心的具体信息。这将带你走过 80%、90%、95% 的路程，
right how do you connect this with things like like cookies and all of that so if you want to know like okay you know this you can access this information if you're logged in as this user. And now you have to like tie in cookies, maybe even Okta. Yeah. Like, how do you tie all of that together without being bound to one language? Right. Yeah. No, that's a really good, that's a really good question.
你如何将它与诸如 Cookie 之类的东西联系起来呢？所以如果你想知道：“好吧，你知道的，如果你以这个用户的身份登录，你就可以访问此信息。”现在你必须把 Cookie 甚至 Okta 串联起来。是的。那么，如何在不被绑定到某种特定语言的情况下，把所有这些串联在一起呢？对吧？是的。不，这是一个非常好的问题。
Right. So we separate authentication from authorization. Right. As, and the industry does this as well. And then in our framework or like in our metadata, we do this as well, right? But what we do is we tell users that in your authorization policies, you can always reference
对吧？所以我们将身份验证（authentication）与授权（authorization）分离开来。对吧？行业里也是这么做的。在我们的框架中，或者在我们的元数据中，我们也是这么做的，对吧？但我们做的是，我们告诉用户，在你的授权策略中，你总是可以引用
the current users or the current sessions properties, right? So you always say in an authorization policy that allow access to this account if account.owner equal to current session.userid, right? Or some property of the current session. So you can basically create complicated Boolean expressions, hierarchical rules that are essentially properties of the data, evaluate and properties of the session that are put together and that expression is evaluated. That essentially is what determines whether you have the ability to access something or not right that's essentially
当前用户或当前会话的属性，对吧？所以你总是在授权策略中这样说：如果 account.owner 等于 current_session.userid，则允许访问此账户，对吧？或者当前会话的某些属性。所以你基本上可以创建复杂的布尔表达式、层级规则，它们本质上是数据的属性、求值结果以及会话属性组合在一起，并对该表达式进行求值。本质上，这就是决定你是否有能力访问某物的东西，对吧？这基本上就是
what all your authorization code is the piece where you convert a cookie or a token into the session information that's a separate piece that you need to kind of specify as a mapping the very nice thing is that, the industry has kind of realized over the last few years that a nice way to approach this problem is a JWT, a JSON web token. So if our cookie or if our header, our authorization header,
你所有的授权代码。将 Cookie 或令牌（token）转换为会话信息的那个部分，是你需要作为映射进行指定的一个单独部分。非常棒的一件事是，行业在过去几年里已经意识到，解决这个问题的绝佳方式是使用 JWT，即 JSON Web 令牌。因此，如果我们的 Cookie 或者我们的请求头——我们的授权请求头——
contains a JSON web token, then a JSON web token is a secure contract. Slightly painful compared to like vanilla, EOB cookies from like 15 years ago right those are much simpler so the jwt adds a little more complex significantly more complexity but it's a common specification that everybody uses octa and not zero and not zero is octa and all but you know everybody uses that jwt now and the jwt is a secure way to to pass on those claims of who the current session is. So in your authorization rules, when you're saying, I want the current session dot something,
包含一个 JSON Web 令牌，那么 JSON Web 令牌就是一个安全契约。与 15 年前朴素的 Cookie 相比，它稍微有点痛苦，对吧？那些要简单得多。所以 JWT 增加了更多的复杂性——显著增加了复杂性，但它是每个人都在使用的通用规范，Okta、Auth0 以及其他所有人——你知道的，现在每个人都在使用 JWT。JWT 是传递当前会话是谁的这些声明的安全方式。所以在你的授权规则中，当你这样说时：“我想要 current_session.某某属性……”
I want current session user ID, current session role, current session region, right? That's a contract that you can specify in your JSON web token. And you can say that my JWT is going to contain these claims. So use these claims to enforce some authorization policy, right? And then when you spin up your web servers, you give them the right keys to be able to decrypt and validate these JSON web tokens. So that's kind of the contract that we have.
我需要当前会话用户 ID、当前会话角色、当前会话区域，对吧？这是一个你可以在 JSON 网络令牌中指定的契约。你可以说我的 JWT 将包含这些声明。然后使用这些声明来强制执行某些授权策略，对吧？接着，当你启动 Web 服务器时，你为它们提供正确的密钥，以便能够解密和验证这些 JSON 网络令牌。所以这有点像是我们拥有的契约。
And that's what makes it easy for everybody to use, right? Like not just us, but like everybody in the world. Got it. Okay, that makes sense. So you do provide like some, so by you, I mean the person using Hasura in this case provides some shim where they say, okay, you know, here's some code that I know Hasura is going to run on server side.
这也是让每个人都能轻松使用的原因，对吧？不仅是我们，还有世界上所有人。明白了。好的，这说得通。所以你的确提供了一些，这里说的“你”是指本例中使用 Hasura 的人，提供了一些填充程序（shim），他们会说，好吧，你知道，这里有一些我知道 Hasura 会在服务器端运行的代码。
This code goes to Okta and, you know, verifies that this cookie is valid and it gives me a list of groups they're in and their, you know, userifies that this cookie is valid. And it gives me a list of groups they're in and their, you know, user ID and everything. Exactly. In fact, with JWT, it's even simpler. You don't need to make that call. This is the reason why people really like JWTs
这段代码会访问 Okta，并且，你知道的，验证这个Cookie是有效的，它会给我提供他们所在的组列表以及他们的，你知道的，验证这个Cookie是有效的。并给我一个他们所在的组列表以及他们的，你知道的，用户ID等等。完全正确。事实上，有了 JWT，这就更简单了。你不需要发起那个调用。这就是人们真的很喜欢 JWT 的原因
because with microservices, everybody realized that when a cookie is coming in, they're going to have to make this extra API call to validate that cookie. So people wanted to skip that step. So the JSON web token itself contains the user ID and information. It contains all of that information already. So you don't need to make an extra call to skip that step. So the JSON web token itself contains the user ID and information. It contains all of that information already.
因为在微服务中，每个人都意识到，当一个Cookie进来时，他们将不得不进行这个额外的 API 调用来验证该Cookie。所以人们希望跳过这一步。因此，JSON 网络令牌本身就包含用户 ID 和信息。它已经包含了所有这些信息。所以你不需要为了跳过这一步而发起额外的调用。因此，JSON 网络令牌本身就包含用户 ID 和信息。它已经包含了所有这些信息。
So you don't need to make an extra call to Okta. What you do instead is you have a key that Okta gives you to validate that the JSON web token was created by Okta in the first place. So that way, it's like somebody sending you their user ID and saying, hey, I'm Tanmay.
所以你不需要对 Okta 进行额外的调用。你取而代之的做法是，拥有一个 Okta 给你的密钥，用来验证该 JSON 网络令牌最初是由 Okta 创建的。这样一来，这就好像有人把他们的用户 ID 发给你，然后说，嘿，我是 Tanmay。
But then you're like, says who? Right? Like the API is like, you their user ID and saying, hey, I'm Tanmay. But then you're like, says who? Right? Like the API is like, you're saying that you're Tanmay, but are you really? Like who told you? Like who verified this? And then you can verify that signature and says, oh, Okta says you're Tanmay. Then you're like, yep, I have Okta's key. And so I trust this.
但随后你会想，谁说的？对吧？就像 API 在说，把他们的用户 ID 发给你，然后说，嘿，我是 Tanmay。但随后你会想，谁说的？对吧？就像 API 在说，你说你是 Tanmay，但你真的是吗？谁告诉你的？谁验证了这个？然后你可以验证那个签名，并说，哦，Okta 说你是 Tanmay。接着你会想，是的，我有 Okta 的密钥。所以我信任这个。
So that's the, so you get to skip that extra lookup step. That's the detail with the JWT. That's the benefit that you get with the JWT. But to your point with with Hustler, we support both of those modes. We support this JWT mode, and your second point, your first point, we support the shim also, where you can provide us a piece
所以这就是，你可以跳过那个额外的查找步骤。这就是 JWT 的细节。这就是你从 JWT 中获得的好处。但就你关于 Hasura 的观点而言，我们支持这两种模式。我们支持这种 JWT 模式，至于你的第二点、你的第一点，我们也支持填充程序（shim），如果你使用的是传统的 JWT 而不是 JSON 网络令牌，你可以向我们提供一段
of code where we can call out to you to do this lookup if it's a traditional JWT and not a JWT. Is there a way in GraphQL to say by default, no one can see anything and then to make it more of like a like an opt-in kind of setup yeah exactly so it depends on how you're building a graphql api right so with hasura when you're building a graphql api that's exactly the
代码，我们可以调用你来执行这个查找。在 GraphQL 中有没有一种方法可以默认说任何人什么都看不到，然后将其变成一种加入式（opt-in）的设置？是的，完全正确。所以这取决于你如何构建 GraphQL API，对吧？所以在 Hasura 中，当你构建一个 GraphQL API 时，这正是我们拥有的
experience that we have right we're like here are all the 10 data sources that you've connected and especially in an enterprise environment right like here are the thousands of models that you have now when you start that experience of building your graphical api you start like creating domain models that are views of these models that you have right and then you start selectively bringing up those models and say that yep this is a part of my api this is a part of my api this is a part of my API. Then you then decide to take a subset of that, the right set of that, transformations of that or whatever, that then become your domain models, right? That actually help somebody who's building a product
体验，对吧？我们就像是，这里是你连接的所有 10 个数据源，特别是在企业环境中，对吧？就像这里有你拥有的成千上万个模型。现在，当你开始构建你的图形 API（graphical api）时，你开始创建作为这些模型的视图的领域模型，对吧？然后你开始有选择地引入这些模型，并说，是的，这是我的 API 的一部分，这是我的 API 的一部分，这是我的 API 的一部分。然后你决定从中取一个子集、正确的集合、其转换或其他什么，这些随后就成了你的领域模型，对吧？这实际上可以帮助构建产品的人
understand what this domain is about. Yeah, I mean, it's a really interesting thing because my experience with GraphQL has been where there hasn't been this synergy. And so what you end up with is a GraphQL model and then one or more databases, and they're not congruent. So it's like if someone comes in saying,
了解这个领域是关于什么的。是的，我的意思是，这是一件非常有趣的事情，因为我对 GraphQL 的经验是，一直没有这种协同效应。所以你最终得到的是一个 GraphQL 模型，然后是一个或多个数据库，它们并不一致。所以这就好像如果有人进来时说，
hey, I want Tanmai's bank account, there's a certain structure that they're providing from the mobile or from the website. And then I, as the sort of front end, back end developer, have to translate that structure into the database structure and say, oh, okay, actually, you know, in this GraphQL request, there's users and users have bank balances. But in my database, there's actually banks and banks have users. And so I have to manually do this. And it becomes very, very painful to have this sort of like dual understanding of the data at all times. And that's exactly what the modeling layer has to solve for you, right? It's like you should be able to, that decoupling, but keeping it cohesive, right?
嘿，我想要 Tanmai 的银行账户，他们从手机或网站上提供了一种特定的结构。然后我，作为前端、后端开发人员，必须将该结构转换为数据库结构，并且说，哦，好吧，实际上，你知道的，在这个 GraphQL 请求中，有用户，用户有银行余额。但在我的数据库中，实际上有银行，银行有用户。所以我必须手动完成这个。并且一直对数据有这种双重理解会变得非常非常痛苦。而这正是建模层必须为你解决的问题，对吧？这就好比你应该能够做到这种解耦，但同时保持内聚，对吧？
That's the work that you need to do with this modeling layer, which, you know, people call semantic modeling or semantic layer or whatever it is, right? But that's like essentially your model layer that describes your domain and maps it to the underlying physical sources that you have. Yeah, but I mean, with something like this, you could have database views. And the database view is nice because it's very descriptive. It's like, okay, I have a table of banks. I have a bank table with user accounts in it, but I'm going to create a view called user bank. And the view inverts that relationship. And then now my API is literally just authorized windows into that view. And now you have full traceability. There's not like Joe who mapped it from A to B in his head. And now Joe quit to join company X, right? Yeah, that's exactly it. And what we do at the Hasura level
这就是你需要通过这个建模层来完成的工作，人们称之为语义建模、语义层或其他什么，对吧？但这基本上就是你的模型层，它描述了你的领域并将其映射到你拥有的底层物理源。是的，但是我的意思是，通过类似这样的东西，你可以拥有数据库视图。而且数据库视图很好，因为它非常具有描述性。它就像是，好吧，我有一个银行表。我有一个带有用户账户的银行表，但我将创建一个名为 user bank 的视图。该视图颠倒了这种关系。然后现在我的 API 实际上只是对该视图的授权窗口。现在你拥有完全的可追踪性。不会像乔那样在脑海中把 A 映射到 B。而现在乔辞职去加入 X 公司了，对吧？是的，完全是这样。我们在 Hasura 层面所做的事情
is that we make it easy for you to create these database views by creating those views in Hasura instead of having to create them in the database. So what happens oftentimes, especially in enterprise environments, is that you don't actually own the database because people are kind of scared to say that,
就是，我们让你能够通过在 Hasura 中创建这些数据库视图来轻松创建它们，而不必在数据库中创建它们。所以往往发生的情况是，尤其是在企业环境中，你实际上并不拥有数据库，因为人们有点害怕说，
oh, somebody's going to come in here and do ddr on my database and create a new table or create a new view so they they sometimes don't want you to have that footprint on the database because it's really important it's like if the database goes down it's screwed right like you're going to lose data you're going to lose like it's it's serious so what you do instead is you create a view at the hasura layer um and so you can create the same view at the Hasura layer, and then Hasura kind of pretends that this is a table. So when Hasura is compiling their GraphQL query
哦，有人会来到这里并在我的数据库上做 ddr（删除重建）并创建一个新表或创建一个新视图，所以他们有时不希望你在数据库上留下这种痕迹，因为这真的很重要，就像如果数据库崩溃了，那就完蛋了，对吧？你会丢失数据，你会丢失像这样的东西，这是很严重的。所以你取而代之的做法是，在 Hasura 层创建一个视图，嗯，所以你可以在 Hasura 层创建相同的视图，然后 Hasura 有点假装这是一张表。因此，当 Hasura 在编译他们的 GraphQL 查询时
into an underlying SQL query, Hasura is essentially like a just-in-time compiler. It takes a GraphQL query, it does a bunch of things, it understands the authorization rules, it compiles it into a SQL query. Like if you're fetching user banks, for example, it would be like a select star from user bank where
转化为底层 SQL 查询，Hasura 本质上就像一个即时编译器（just-in-time compiler）。它获取一个 GraphQL query，做一堆事情，理解授权规则，然后将其编译成一个 SQL 查询。比如，如果你要获取用户银行，它会像是 select star from user bank where
id equal to current session.id. So it adds that where clause essentially, right? Because that's what your policy had. But it's not select star from user bank, it's select star from complicated logical model view, right? So when we're creating, so we're compiling it into the right thing
id equal to current session.id。所以它基本上添加了那个 where 子句，对吧？因为那是你的策略所拥有的。但它不是 select star from user bank，而是 select star from 复杂的逻辑模型视图，对吧？所以当我们创建时，我们将其编译成正确的东西，
that reflects what your data sources have. And then, of course, because it's GraphQL, what you can also do is create relationships between models. So you can say, cool, I got this user bank model here, but user bank has city and city has weather. So I want to add weather to this user bank information, but the weather comes from an external API. So what Hasura allows you to do is create a relationship and says, user bank has .city and.city is connected to the weather service. So weather, because weather service exposes weather per city. And so now you can enrich that model. So now from a GraphQL point of view, you're getting user bank and then you're getting.city weather in one query. And these two
以反映你的数据源所拥有的。然后，当然，因为它是 GraphQL，你还可以做的一件事是创建模型之间的关系。所以你可以说，酷，我这里有这个 user bank 模型，但是 user bank 有 city，city 有 weather。所以我想将 weather 添加到这个 user bank 信息中，但是 weather 来自外部 API。因此，Hasura 允许你做的是创建一个关系并说，user bank 具有 .city，而 .city 连接到 weather 服务。所以 weather，因为 weather 服务按城市公开天气。所以现在你可以丰富该模型了。因此，从 GraphQL 的角度来看，你可以在一个查询中获取 user bank，然后获取 .city weather。并且这两个
models are connected. And Hasura is doing that work of figuring out, all right, you have a model here, you have a model here. This is a relationship. We'll do the work for you to figure out how to cache, compile, query, whatever, right? And that becomes very useful. Because again, you're just authorizing weather data. You're authorizing user bank information.
模型是连接的。Hasura 正在做的工作是弄清楚，好吧，你这里有一个模型，你这里有一个模型。这是一个关系。我们将为你完成弄清楚如何缓存、编译、查询等的工作，对吧？这变得非常有用。因为再次强调，你只是在授权天气数据。你正在授权 user bank 信息。
You're creating semantic models. You're creating relationships. This is the work you want to do. And you get an API. Very, very cool. Oh, you know, one thing we should talk about is definitely like, you know, there's a Hasura platform. Let's say folks want to use just vanilla GraphQL to get started. So someone might have a REST API. They might have a simple website they built, a REST API, a Node.js backend.
你正在创建语义模型。你正在创建关系。这就是你想做的工作。然后你得到了一个 API。非常非常酷。哦，你知道，我们应该讨论的一件事绝对是，你知道的，有一个 Hasura 平台。比方说，人们想使用纯粹的 GraphQL 来开始。所以有人可能有一个 REST API。他们可能建立了一个简单的网站、一个 REST API、一个 Node.js 后端。
And they say, oh, I think this GraphQL thing is perfect for me. How would you recommend people learn about GraphQL and then port REST apps over? What's your advice there? I'm sure you've done it a lot, have a lot of experience there. Yeah, yeah. There's a bunch of things you can do. So I would recommend, so there's a bunch of learning resources that lots of that the community maintains so we have a bunch of open source tutorials that we maintain at hustler.io slash learn where you can go and kind of start playing around with GraphQL and getting a sense of what GraphQL is like if it's going to be a good API for you and stuff like that that gets you started in like a under
然后他们说，哦，我觉得这个 GraphQL 东西对我很完美。你推荐人们如何学习 GraphQL 然后将 REST 应用迁移过来？你有什么建议吗？我确信你做过很多次，在那方面有很多经验。是的，是的。你可以做一堆事情。所以我会推荐，所以有很多学习资源，社区维护了许多这样的资源，我们在 hasura.io/learn 维护了一堆开源教程，你可以在那里开始试玩 GraphQL，了解 GraphQL 是什么样的，看看它是否会成为适合你的好 API 等等，这能让你在不到
a minute basically I think if you're building your own GraphQL API that is mapping to REST API services you have a bunch of options. So there's a bunch of frameworks that are kind of helping you convert REST APIs into GraphQL natively, especially if you have an open API specification that you can convert. So Hustler does that.
一分钟的时间内基本上上手，我想如果你正在构建自己的映射到 REST API 服务的 GraphQL API，你有很多选择。所以有很多框架可以帮助你在本地将 REST API 转换为 GraphQL，特别是如果你有一个可以转换的开放 API 规范的话。所以 Hasura 可以做到这一点。
You can kind of bring in a REST API, create a GraphQL type for it and get a GraphQL API. The other way, if you want to just like write that GraphQL server code yourself and get a feel for what it to just write that GraphQL server code yourself and get a feel for what it takes to build a GraphQL server, and once you do that, you'll never want to do it again because it's like
你可以引入一个 REST API，为其创建一个 GraphQL 类型，并获得一个 GraphQL API。另一种方法是，如果你只想自己编写该 GraphQL 服务器代码，并感受一下编写 GraphQL 服务器需要什么，一旦你这样做了，你就再也不想这样做了，因为它就像是
a lot of work. It's good to do it, but you probably don't want to do it continuously. It's similar to building a SQL server. Nobody builds servers that speak SQL because there's a query that comes in, you parse the query and you create a query plan
大量的工作。这样做很好，但你可能不想连续这样做。这类似于构建一个 SQL 服务器。没有人构建说 SQL 的服务器，因为有一个进来的查询，你解析查询并创建一个查询计划
and you optimize it, right? And you do all this work and then you're like, actually, I don't want to, I'll buy a database. Yeah, like compiling your own kernel or something. I mean, you know. Right, right. So you don't do, yeah, you typically want to kind of not do that work,
并对其进行优化，对吧？你做了所有这些工作，然后你想，实际上，我不想这样，我会买一个数据库。是的，就像编译你自己的内核什么的。我的意思是，你知道的。对，对。所以你不会，是的，你通常倾向于不做那项工作，
but it's worth kind of doing that just to get a feel for it, right? and i think that depending on whatever programming language you're familiar with by the way patrick is twitching right now as soon as i said compiling your own kernel is something you never want to do i saw patrick's eyebrow go up patrick is the so just to give you some background time patrick's like a embedded software engineer of the two and i uh my code looks terrible by comparison. Yeah. And he's like, why are people so scared of compiling their own cards?
但为了感受一下，还是值得这样做的，对吧？而且我认为，不管你熟悉什么编程语言，顺便说一句，帕特里克（Patrick）现在正在抽搐，就在我说编译你自己的内核是你永远不想做的事情时，我看到帕特里克的眉毛扬了起来。帕特里克是……所以为了给你一些背景信息，坦迈，帕特里克是两人中精通嵌入式软件的工程师，而我……相比之下，我的代码看起来太糟糕了。是的。而他就像，为什么人们这么害怕编译自己的内核？
You do it for me, right? I do it for breakfast, then I do it for brunch. You don't write compilers for your compilers that compile your code to code? Exactly. Right? But yeah, I think to your point, you know, GraphQL, like using like Apollo directly or something is good to do a couple of
你替我做，对吧？我把它当早餐吃，然后再当早午餐吃。你难道不为你的编译器编写编译器，把你的代码编译成代码吗？完全正确。对吧？但是，是的，我认为正如你所说，你知道，GraphQL，像直接使用 Apollo 或类似的东西，做几次是好的，
times, but yeah, like for example, if you're using Node.js, Apollo has a bunch of libraries and there's a bunch of others, but you can do it. Like GraphQL has GraphQL Java, .NET has,
但是，是的，比如如果你在使用 Node.js，Apollo 有一堆库，还有其他很多库，但你可以做到这一点。就像 GraphQL 有 GraphQL Java，.NET 有，
I think chocolate, it's called hot chocolate. Every programming language has a bunch of frameworks, but I think once you do it once or twice, you will just be like i i know let's use a thing that helps us because i want a graphql api the experience um and i already have these sources of data maybe they rest maybe they're like sad services legacy their services databases whatever it is and i'd like a graphql api so that's typically kind of the curve that we see as well, right?
我想是 chocolate，它叫 hot chocolate。每种编程语言都有一堆框架，但我认为一旦你做了一两次，你就会觉得，我知道了，让我们使用一个能帮助我们的东西，因为我想要 GraphQL API 的体验，
We see a lot of people kind of like using GraphQL and then running into like performance and observability issues and then kind of saying that, ah, okay, I would like to like automate this layer because I like GraphQL, but the building of the GraphQL is a little bit painful. That makes sense.
而且我已经有了这些数据源，也许它们是 REST，也许它们是像 sad 服务、遗留服务、数据库或其他什么，我想要一个 GraphQL API。所以这通常也是我们看到曲线的地方，对吧？我们看到很多人开始使用 GraphQL，然后遇到性能和可观察性问题，然后说，啊，好吧，我想自动化这一层，因为我喜欢 GraphQL，但构建 GraphQL 有点痛苦。这说得通。
So with something like Hasura, that's kind of end to end, how do you deal with transactions, right? So if I need to execute a handful of mutations and roll back if it doesn't work, I know that, I mean, if I was writing this by hand, I would have a GraphQL mutation, and that mutation would have a ton of business logic
所以对于像 Hasura 这样端到端的东西，你如何处理事务，对吧？所以如果我需要执行一小部分变更（mutations）并且在它不工作时回滚，我知道，我的意思是，如果我自己手写这个，我会有一个 GraphQL 变更，并且该变更会有大量的业务逻辑，
that all is wrapped around a session, you know, commit. Yeah. How do you handle stuff like that? Yeah. Yeah. So we do two things, right? So it depends.
所有这些都围绕着一个会话（session）、你知道的、提交（commit）进行包装。是的。你们是如何处理类似事情的？是的。是的。所以我们做两件事，对吧？所以这取决于。
For example, if your, if your transactions are simple, we support transactions over GraphQL itself. So you can run a sequence of mutations and they'll all be all or nothing. So it'll all be like a sequence of like, you can do create, create, create, read, update, delete, whatever. And it's a sequence and you can execute that sequence in an all or nothing kind of way. This works only if each of those models are independently secured. It doesn't work if the transaction as a concept
例如，如果你的事务很简单，我们支持直接在 GraphQL 上进行事务。因此，你可以运行一系列变更，它们将全部成功或全部失败（all or nothing）。因此，它将全部像是一个序列，你可以执行创建、创建、创建、读取、更新、删除等操作，这是一个序列，你可以以全部成功或全部失败的方式执行该序列。这仅在其中每个模型都独立受安全保护时才有效。如果作为概念的事务
is centralized logic that can't be controlled, like a bank transaction. Even if you secure each of the models inside, like accounts and transactions, you still can't allow a device to run that transaction from a user device. It has to be the user saying, run this transaction for me, and that code has to run in a centralized security context. So what we do for those are we allow users to have two common patterns. The first pattern is an event-driven pattern. So what we do is, I don't know if you're familiar with CQRS
是无法控制的集中式逻辑，比如银行事务，这就行不通了。即使你保护了里面的每个模型，比如账户和事务，你仍然不能允许设备从用户设备运行该事务。必须是用户说，为我运行这个事务，并且该代码必须在集中式安全上下文中运行。所以对于这些情况，我们允许用户采用两种常见的模式。第一种模式是事件驱动模式。所以我们做的是，我不知道你是否熟悉 CQRS
or CQS as a pattern, basically command and query segregation, right? No, I haven't heard of that. Oh, so CQS, CQR is a common pattern for like building and designing microservices and scaling them, where the idea is that you have a read model. So you have models that you can read from, and then you have something called a command model. And so the command model does is that the user provides an input. The input is a command. And then that command then is an event that fires off a transaction
或 CQS 作为一种模式，基本上就是命令查询职责分离（command and query segregation），对吧？不，我没听说过。哦，所以 CQS，CQR 是构建和设计微服务以及对其进行扩展的常见模式，其核心思想是你有一个读取模型。所以你有可以从中读取的模型，然后你有一些叫做命令模型的东西。所以命令模型的作用是用户提供输入。输入是一个命令。然后该命令随后是一个触发事务的事件，
that needs to run, that goes and does a bunch of things and updates a bunch of models and data models. And then you can read from the models that you've updated so so what hasura does in this context is it's like a firm submission right so somebody says hey i want to do a bank transaction so that input comes to hasura hasura validates the input of the command is valid right meaning that it's a user a creating it it's an integer number less than whatever some validation rules right um and then hustler just hands that off to a workflow system a transactional system an http serverless function a stored procedure inside an oracle database
该事务需要运行，去执行一堆事情并更新一堆模型和数据模型。然后你可以从你更新的模型中读取。所以 Hasura 在这种情况下所做的是，它就像一个表单提交，对吧？所以有人说，嘿，我想做一个银行事务。所以该输入来到 Hasura，Hasura 验证命令的输入是否有效，对吧，这意味着是用户 a 创建的，它是一个小于某个值的整数，有一些验证规则，嗯，然后 Hasura 只是把那个交给工作流系统、事务系统、HTTP 无服务器函数、Oracle 数据库内部的存储过程，
whatever it is we don't care we hand that off to something that runs your centralized logic, right? So we take care of the API contract that's coming in from the edge, and then we hand it off to some centralized logic and we support a bunch that can run. And we do it over events so that it scales easily. That centralized logic does whatever it needs to do. And then when the output kind of comes to us, we then enrich that output back into GraphQL. So you can say, do a bank transaction and the output contains a reference to the account, and you can do a GraphQL query on the account. So you can fetch the account information and whatever has been updated. So this CQRS pattern is kind of what Hasura allows for. What we want
无论是什么，我们不在乎。我们把它交给某些运行你的集中式逻辑的东西，对吧？所以我们处理从边缘进来的 API 契约，然后我们把它交给我们支持的、可以运行的一堆集中式逻辑。我们通过事件来做到这一点，以便它可以轻松扩展。该集中式逻辑做它需要做的任何事情。然后当输出结果传回给我们时，我们将该输出丰富并返回到 GraphQL 中。所以你可以说，执行一个银行事务，输出包含对账户的引用，并且你可以对账户执行 GraphQL 查询。所以你可以获取账户信息和任何已更新的内容。所以这个 CQRS 模式正是 Hasura 所允许的。我们想要
to do is not interfere with business logic on either side. So we don't want to interfere with product business logic or centralized logic. So we just take care of the API contract and then you write your logic however you want to write your logic. But you write your logic without caring about GraphQL. You write your logic just caring about what data systems you have. That makes sense. In complex enterprise environments especially what we see is your one mutation that has all the transaction logic also doesn't scale. Because what ends up happening is that this transaction is often a workflow across multiple services, right? When you don't even get transaction semantics, where what you need to do is do something like create user is like create user as a transaction on database one, send email, initialize data, right?
做的是不干扰任何一侧的业务逻辑。所以我们不想干扰产品业务逻辑或集中式逻辑。所以我们只处理 API 契约，然后你随心所欲地编写你的逻辑。但是你编写逻辑时不用关心 GraphQL。你编写逻辑时只关心你拥有什么数据系统。这说得通。尤其是在复杂的企业环境中，我们看到的是，拥有所有事务逻辑的单个变更也无法扩展。因为最终发生的情况是，这个事务通常是跨多个服务的工作流，对吧？当你在甚至无法获得事务语义的情况下，你需要做的是做类似这样的事情：创建用户就像是数据库 1 上的创建用户事务、发送电子邮件、初始化数据，对吧？
Like it's like three different services that you need to hit. And so what people end up doing for that is they prefer a workflow engine to orchestrate across these services. And so then what Hustler helps you do is say, hey, we got the input for you and we validated it. And now as this workflow runs,
就像你需要命中的三个不同的服务。所以人们最终为此做的是，他们更喜欢工作流引擎来跨这些服务进行编排。然后 Hasura 帮助你做的是说，嘿，我们为你获取了输入并且我们验证了它。现在随着这个工作流的运行，
you can actually subscribe to real-time updates on that workflow. So we often see this pattern, It's called a mutation subscription pair. So you send a mutation and then you get a workflow ID response and then you subscribe to that workflow ID. And then you'll see those updates coming in as your transaction executes across this workflow. And that's what you see in like, you know, like a DoorDash when you're placing an order, right? Like you're seeing that kind of experience. So that's what hustler does does that make sense yeah that totally makes sense yeah no it's a fantastic description i think uh yeah i think it's a
你实际上可以订阅该工作流的实时更新。所以我们经常看到这种模式，它被称为变更订阅对（mutation subscription pair）。所以你发送一个变更，然后你得到一个工作流 ID 响应，然后你订阅那个工作流 ID。然后你会看到随着你的事务在这个工作流中执行而进来的那些更新。这就是你在类似 DoorDash 下订单时看到的那种体验，对吧？就像你看到了那种体验。这就是 Hasura 所做的。这说得通吗？是的，这完全说得通。是的，不，这是一个非常棒的描述。我想，是的，我认为这是一个
really good way of putting it basically if it's something relatively small like then it literally is a transaction that executes in in kind of one round trip then you have ways to do that but then to your point you know most of the time you have these transactions, there's either a human in the loop or if there's not, there's an external system in the loop. And so you don't really want to just block until it's all done. What you really want is to just say, this is out the door and I'll tell you. And basically things are inconsistent until you know we're done so so you might say yeah you might say like go and spend all my money in my bank account they say okay we're
很好的表达方式，基本上，如果它是一个相对较小的东西，那么它字面上就是在一个往返中执行的事务，那么你有办法做到这一点。但正如你所说，你知道，大多数时候你拥有这些事务，要么有人工参与，要么如果没有，则有外部系统参与。所以你真的不想只是阻塞直到全部完成。你真正想要的只是说，这个已经发出去了，我会通知你的。并且基本上事情是不一致的，直到你知道我们完成了。所以你可能会说，是的，你可能会说，去花掉我银行账户里的所有钱，他们说，好的，我们在
working on it and maybe you know for that moment you still have money in your bank account and then and but but that's that's kind of to be expected because you know the user experience is like this isn't going to happen you happen in a microsecond. This is like a long running thing. Exactly. Exactly. Right. And there's like all of the API issues are also often at this layer.
处理了，也许，你知道的，在那一刻你账户里仍然有钱，然后，但是，但这是可以预料的，因为用户体验就像是这不会在微秒内发生。这是一个长期运行的事情。完全正确。完全正确。对吧？并且所有的 API 问题通常也都在这一层。
Right. So one of the common patterns here that becomes a pain is scaling rights is always a challenge. Right. Because when you have a high volume of rights, like how do you scale that? And so what people typically do is they buffer it. So what you do is, suddenly we had a spike of 1 million events. 1 million writes happened. So you don't actually try to make your database do 1 million transactions because it can't.
对吧。所以这里成为痛点的常见模式之一是，扩展写入始终是一个挑战。对吧。因为当你拥有高容量的写入时，你如何扩展它？所以人们通常的做法是缓冲它。所以你做的是，突然我们有了一百万个事件的峰值。发生了一百万次写入。所以你实际上不会试图让你的数据库执行一百万次事务，因为它做不到。
And so what you do instead is you grab these 1 million events and you buffer them into a queue. And then the queue then outputs them at a throttled rate that your database can handle right so you tell people that yep i've gotten your order and i've gotten your transaction request and we're processing it give us a set so you queue it up and you let the transactions happen over time and the end user gets real-time visibility into like what's happening right they're like yep it's still processing or whatever. And then when it kind of finishes or it gets taken up for processing, that's when the user gets to know.
所以你取而代之的做法是，获取这一百万个事件并将它们缓冲到队列中。然后队列以你的数据库可以处理的节流速率输出它们，对吧？所以你告诉人们，是的，我已经收到了你的订单，我已经收到了你的事务请求，我们正在处理它，给我们一会，所以你把它排队，让事务随着时间发生，最终用户获得对正在发生的事情的实时可见性，对吧？他们就像，是的，它仍在处理中，或者别的什么。然后当它某种程度上完成或被拿去处理时，用户才会知道。
So those kinds of things start happening, and that's what the Hustler layer does. Because that's the reason why everybody's saying that you want to have event-based systems. You want to have event-driven systems. This is the idea because a monolithic system can't scale. Yeah, like even as we speak, as we speak, they're still trying to liquidate NFT tokens. It's been going for about six months now,
所以这类事情开始发生，这就是 Hasura 层所做的工作。因为这就是为什么每个人都在说你希望拥有基于事件的系统。你希望拥有事件驱动的系统。这就是这个想法，因为单体系统无法扩展。是的，就像在我们说话的同时，在我们说话的同时，他们仍在试图清算 NFT 代币。已经进行了大约六个月了，
24 hours a day, seven days a week. And they're still trying to sell those NFT tokens. It's queued up. Yeah, it's still in the queue oh man um no this is awesome so let's let's uh talk a little bit about hasura we talked about you know some things it can do let's talk a little bit about you know in terms of of folks who are just getting started is there a free tier your high school students college students we have a lot of those folks listening to podcasts can they can they use Hasura for free? You know, how does that work?
每周七天，每天二十四小时。他们仍在试图出售那些 NFT 代币。它排队了。是的，它还在队列里。天哪，不，这太棒了。所以让我们，让我们稍微讨论一下 Hasura，我们讨论了它能做的一些事情，让我们稍微讨论一下，对于刚刚起步的人来说，有没有免费层级？你的高中生、大学生，有很多这样的人在听播客，他们可以免费使用 Hasura 吗？你知道，那是怎么运作的？
Yep, there's a free tier on our managed service, it's open source as well. So download the Docker image and start playing around with it. And there's a pretty generous free tier on our cloud service as well. So you don't need to download a Docker image and run it if you don't want to. We've partnered with Neon on the Postgres side as well. So that means that you have free tier Postgres as well. So, you know, you can log into Hasura, create like a free tier Postgres and start actually building the API.
是的，我们的托管服务上有一个免费层级，它也是开源的。所以下载 Docker 镜像并开始玩转它。并且我们的云服务上也有一个非常慷慨的免费层级。所以如果你不想的话，你不需要下载 Docker 镜像并运行它。我们在 Postgres 方面也与 Neon 进行了合作。这意味着你也有免费层级的 Postgres。所以，你知道的，你可以登录 Hasura，创建一个免费层级的 Postgres 并开始实际构建 API。
And I think within a few minutes, you'll realize that you've probably saved like writing a week worth of code because you're just creating models and getting an API. So that's one of the easiest ways to get started. Very, very cool. And as far as Hasura, the company,
而且我认为在几分钟内，你会意识到你可能节省了一周的代码编写时间，因为你只是在创建模型并获取 API。所以这是最简单的入门方法之一。非常非常酷。就 Hasura 这家公司而言，
where are you all based? Is it a remote-first company? Or if it's not, where are the offices? And what's it kind of like over there? We're about 150 people spread across five continents. But we're kind of centered mostly around our hq is san francisco so we have folks in the bay area and then we have another uh centered bangalore in
你们总部在哪里？这是一家远程优先的公司吗？如果不是，办公室在哪里？那里感觉怎么样？我们大约有 150 人，分布在五大洲。但我们的中心主要围绕我们的总部，即旧金山，所以在湾区有员工，然后我们在印度的
india and that's another hub so these are kind of the two hubs um and that's where most people are but then otherwise we're also fairly remote so assuming ant Antarctica is out, and what is the sixth continent? Do you not have anyone in Australia or Africa? I feel like it could go either way. No, actually, hold on. I think we're now in sixth then. North America, South America, Asia, Africa, Australia. Yeah, yeah, Europe.
班加罗尔还有另一个中心，那是另一个枢纽。所以这些大致是两个枢纽，大多数人在那里，但除此之外我们也是相当远程的。所以假设南极洲除外，第六大洲是什么？你们在澳大利亚或非洲没有人吗？我觉得哪种都有可能。不，等等，等一下。我想我们现在有六个了。北美洲、南美洲、亚洲、非洲、澳大利亚。是的，是的，欧洲。
Yeah, that's true. Wow, six. You just need to have. Yeah, that's true. Wow, six. You just need to have someone in that South Pole office. Yeah, exactly, right? I mean, it's just a matter of time. Yeah, that's right. No, that is very cool. Are you all looking to hire?
是的，确实如此。哇，六个。你只需要有。是的，确实如此。哇，六个。你只需要在那个南极洲办公室里有个人。是的，完全正确，对吧？我的意思是，这只是时间问题。是的，没错。不，这非常酷。你们在招聘吗？
Is it full-time interns? We are. We're always hiring. And so you'll see it on hustler.io slash jobs or hustler.io slash careers um or just follow linkedin as well and we're often hiring we hire folks at all levels across a variety of roles uh product engineering uh go-to market which is marketing sales uh all of our roles are pretty technical and so especially if you, you know, come from
是全职实习生吗？是的。我们一直在招聘。所以你会在 hasura.io/jobs 或 hasura.io/careers 上看到它，或者只需关注领英（LinkedIn），我们经常在招聘。我们在各个层级、各种角色中招聘员工，包括产品工程、市场开拓（go-to market），也就是营销、销售。我们所有的角色都相当技术性，所以特别是如果你来自
a technical background or want to enter technology, you're a developer and you want to build something for developers, that kind of thing is what we basically run on. And so keep an eye out on that and follow LinkedIn. And we hire full time folks, we hire interns as well. And so just kind of watch out for that. Cool cool what's the what's the best way for people to get sort of noticed i think it's if you depends on what role you're applying for but we really like it when you have experience with uh the domain and the product so if you build something with hasuro and you know if it's like even if it's a toy application or it's a serious application or you build it at work or something like that, that's,
技术背景，或者想进入科技行业，你是一名开发人员，并且想为开发人员构建一些东西，我们基本上就是靠这种事情运营的。所以请留意这一点并关注领英。我们招聘全职员工，我们也招聘实习生。所以只需留意这一点。酷，酷。人们获得关注的最佳方式是什么？我认为这取决于你申请的是什么职位，但如果我们真的喜欢你对这个领域和产品有经验的话，那会更好。所以如果你用 Hasura 构建了某些东西，你知道的，即使它是一个玩具应用程序或是一个严肃的应用程序，或者你在工作中使用它构建了某些东西，那是，
you know, you just having that context is phenomenal for us. And whenever we see in our applications that people have kind of used Hasura or have experience with it or have, or even in adjacent domains, right? Like for example, the database domain or the mobile web domain or the GraphQL domain and have touched upon or built adjacent concepts that Hasura has built on, that's always great for us. So, you know, the way that you showcase that could be through a portfolio, a website, it could be through an application that you built, could be through a technical blog that you have. So, you know, just having a profile and especially if that profile is immediately relevant or adjacent to what Hasura does, that's always very helpful for us to understand you and your application and process
你知道的，拥有这种背景对我们来说太棒了。每当我们在申请中看到人们使用过 Hasura 或有相关经验，或者甚至在邻近领域，对吧？例如，数据库领域或移动网络领域或 GraphQL 领域，并且接触过或构建过 Hasura 构建的邻近概念，这对我们来说总是很好的。所以，你知道的，你展示这一点的方式可以通过作品集、网站、你构建的应用程序、你拥有的技术博客。所以，你知道的，只需拥有一个个人资料，特别是如果该个人资料与 Hasura 所做的事情直接相关或相邻，这对我们理解你、你的应用程序并更快地处理
that faster. Yeah, that makes sense. Very cool. This is absolutely phenomenal. I wanted to ask you kind of a, you know, one thing that we have on the show is we have a book of the show. And when we're doing interviews, we love to ask our interviewer, what is their favorite book? Now, I know you haven't watched every episode. If you recommend a book we've already recommended, that's totally fine. But what is a book that you recommend, especially folks getting started in tech or people who are interested in GraphQL, or it doesn't have to be super technical. What's a book you'd recommend to people with that mindset? I would say when it comes to kind of technology,
这些总是非常有帮助的。是的，这说得通。非常酷。这绝对是太棒了。我想问你一个，你知道的，我们在节目中有一个传统，就是我们有节目之书（book of the show）。当我们进行采访时，我们喜欢问采访对象，他们最喜欢的书是什么？现在，我知道你没有看过每一集。如果你推荐一本我们已经推荐过的书，那完全没问题。但是你推荐的一本书是什么，特别是对于刚进入科技领域的人，或者对 GraphQL 感兴趣的人，或者它不必是超级技术的。对于有这种心态的人，你推荐什么书？我会说，当涉及到某种技术时，
like GraphQL-like things, the best way is to just do. And so finding resources that are close to, like if you're like a Python developer, finding something that is close to the Python ecosystem and building that out and then kind of branching out from there is what I found to be the most useful.
比如类似于 GraphQL 的东西，最好的方法就是去实践。所以寻找接近，比如如果你是一个 Python 开发者，寻找接近 Python 生态系统并构建出来的资源，然后从那里分支出去，这是我发现最有用的方法。
And so I don't think I've ever read like a technology book since university. No, sure. But like, what's a book that, you know, just for people who have that mindset, it could be,
所以我想自从大学毕业后，我就再也没有读过技术书。不，当然。但是，有什么书是，你知道的，对于有这种心态的人，它可以是，
you know, there's a, there's a book called the hard thing about hard things. I think that's what it's called, but it's a book. it's Ben Horowitz. Yeah. So just what's a book that, you know, that kind of audience would appreciate that you've read recently or that you are really fond of? I think a little more on kind of perhaps the leadership side of things. A book that I've really enjoyed, I think is perhaps the best book on like business strategy that I've read is a book called Good Strategy, Bad Strategy, which is a short book. It's I think the only book on strategy that has actually made sense and is actionable and
你知道的，有一本叫做《硬事之硬》（The Hard Thing About Hard Things）的书。我想那是它的名字，但它是一本书。是本·霍罗威茨（Ben Horowitz）写的。是的，那么有什么书是，你知道的，那种受众会欣赏的，你最近读过或你真的很喜欢的？我想稍微偏向领导力方面一点。我真的很喜欢的一本书，我认为可能是我读过的关于商业战略最好的书是一本叫做《好战略，坏战略》（Good Strategy, Bad Strategy）的书，这是一本短小的书。我想这是唯一一本真正讲得通、具有可操作性且
concrete. I've heard about this book. I haven't read it, but you're the nth person to recommend it to me. So this is definitely i'm gonna have to check it out yes it's amazing it's a really nice lead and i think you can apply it at all levels of anytime you need to rely anytime you feel like you want a strategy around something right especially with a team right so so it becomes really helpful for all of that and and surprising because most books on strategy are useful during peacetime and not wartime. So peacetime, wartime is like, I think it's from the Ben Horowitz, Hard Things About Hard Things. Right, right.
具体的战略书。我听说过这本书。我没读过，但你是第 n 个向我推荐它的人。所以这绝对是我得去看看的。是的，太棒了。这是一本非常好的领导力书籍，我认为你可以在所有层面上随时随地应用它，当你需要围绕某事依赖某种战略时，对吧，特别是团队，对吧？所以这对所有这些都非常有用，而且令人惊讶，因为大多数关于战略的书在和平时期有用，而不是在战时。所以和平时期，战时，就像是，我想这是来自本·霍罗威茨的《硬事之硬》。对，对。
It's like description of peacetime, wartime, right? So most strategy books are very like peacetime descriptions of like, oh, everything's going along well and you need to improve something. And so let's create a strategy around it or whatever. But I found good strategy, by strategy to be really good even like we need to get something done in three months or we'll die or you know you need to do something over four years and it's a big transformation that's going to take time so that's a book i've really really enjoyed very very cool yeah it looks like the author is richard rumley i don't know if that's french or if it's rumlet but uh yeah very cool yeah we'll put it
这就像是对和平时期、战时的描述，对吧？所以大多数战略书都是非常类似和平时期的描述，比如，哦，一切都进展顺利，你需要改进某些东西。所以让我们围绕它制定战略什么的。但我发现《好战略，坏战略》真的很好，即使像我们需要在三个月内完成某事否则我们就会死，或者你知道的你需要花四年时间做某事，这是一个需要时间的重大转型，所以这是一本我非常非常喜欢的书。非常非常酷。是的，看起来作者是理查德·鲁梅尔特（Richard Rumelt），我不知道那是法语还是 Rumlet，但是，是的，非常非常酷。是的，我们会把它
in the show notes and folks can check it out thanks a lot for suggesting that i think it's uh i've heard many good things about that book so uh it's a short book which is nice yeah totally yeah it looks like let me see if i can get the page count here say oh it says uh it's 11 hours on audio which is yeah pretty pretty oh here we go. So yeah, it's not bad at all. You could knock that out in a weekend. Cool. This was amazing. I think we covered GraphQL in great depth. I'm a huge GraphQL fan. I think, you know, I have seen in previous companies, people accidentally expose things in GraphQL because it is so powerful. And that is always something to be concerned of,
放在节目笔记中，大家可以去看看。非常感谢你提出这个建议，我认为它，我听过很多关于那本书的好话，所以，这是一本短小的书，这很好。是的，完全是的，看起来，让我看看我能不能在这里拿到页数，哦，它说，在音频上是 11 小时，这确实是，相当相当，哦，这里我们看到了。所以，是的，一点也不坏。你可以在一个周末把它啃完。酷。这太棒了。我想我们深入探讨了 GraphQL。我是 GraphQL 的超级粉丝。我想，你知道的，我在以前的公司里看到过，人们因为 GraphQL 太强大而意外地暴露了东西。而这总是需要担心的事，
which is why, again, having some kind of authorization, as we talked about, is extremely important. But provided you get that right, it's one of these things that becomes more and more important as you go along. And so if you start off on the right foot, it's much easier to keep running. It's much harder when you have, you know, 300 REST calls and, you know, 40 different clients to have to move over to GraphQL. So it's good to learn these things, you know, off the bat. You know, I love how we kind of dovetailed into, you know, how do we connect the model into this database? Really phenomenal. And thank you so much, Tanmay, for having the time to spend with us here today likewise it was a super fun conversation
这就是为什么再次强调，正如我们所讨论的那样，拥有某种授权是极其重要的。但只要你把这一点弄对了，随着你的进行，它就会变得越来越重要。所以如果你以正确的脚步行事，继续运行就会容易得多。当你拥有 300 个 REST 调用和 40 个不同的客户端不得不迁移到 GraphQL 时，要困难得多。所以最好一开始就了解这些事情。你知道，我喜欢我们如何自然过渡到，你知道的，我们如何将模型连接到这个数据库？真的非常了不起。非常感谢 Tanmay 今天抽出时间陪我们度过。同样，这是一次非常有趣的对话。
and uh you know for folks as well feel free to reach out to me if you want to chat about data or graphql or apis and product stuff so i'm always around yeah definitely we'll put it out in the notes but just uh to put in this show do you have a particular way that you like to be reached out to is it twitter linkedin it does it does better okay very cool yeah we'll put it in the show notes so if you're listening on just about any podcast app you should be able to swipe right and unlike getting like a tinder girlfriend or something you'll actually get the show notes and you can go and click on a twitter handle you can click on the programming throwdown page you get the notes in html You can also support the show on Patreon,
还有，你知道的，对于大家来说，如果你想聊聊数据、GraphQL、API或产品相关的事情，也欢迎随时联系我，我随时都在。好的，当然，我们会把它写在shownotes里，但为了在节目中说明，你有什么特别喜欢被联系的方式吗？是Twitter还是LinkedIn？LinkedIn效果更好。好的，非常酷。是的，我们会把它写在shownotes里，所以如果你在几乎任何播客应用上收听，你应该都可以向右滑动，不像在Tinder上找女朋友什么的，你实际上能看到shownotes，你可以点击Twitter账号，可以点击Programming Throwdown的页面，你能在HTML中看到这些。你也可以在Patreon上支持本节目，
which we really appreciate. We take all of the donations from the show and we use it to improve the show and also bring new people. We've brought a lot of new folks into Programming Throwdown and it's just so great. There's actually an email we got, Patrick and I got today from somebody who learned C++ for the first time is just getting started. And that always kind of fills our cup, warms our spirit. So we really appreciate that. And appreciate you, Tadmai, for coming on this show. And look forward to catching up in the future. Likewise.
我们对此非常感激。我们把节目的所有捐赠都用来改进节目，并邀请新嘉宾。我们为Programming Throwdown邀请了许多新朋友，这真是太棒了。事实上，我和帕特里克今天收到了一封某位第一次学习C++并刚刚入门的听众发来的电子邮件。这总是能让我们感到充实和温暖。所以我们真的非常感谢。也感谢你，Tadmai，来到本节目。并期待在未来与你交流。同样如此。
Thanks for having me. Music by Eric Barndollar. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Share Alike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide an attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢邀请我。音乐由Eric Barndollar创作。Programming Throwdown在知识共享 署名-相同方式共享 2.0 协议下分发。您可以自由共享、复制、分发、传输本作品，以及重新混合、改编本作品，但您必须向我和帕特里克提供署名，并以相同方式共享。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可留下评论。